it's very oh that's true you are very
close to get close to Conan I mean like
if you're like a stalker you wanna hurt
Conan too right
but like if you're just like really into
Conan come on over there make a t-shirt
you might have t-shirts beloved sign you
might get a little piece of spit when he
talks a time during like a monologue
like right there oh my god what happened
to the Conan gum did somebody throw it
away all right here's the backstory this
is gross and I'm sorry Conan had gum and
we kept it here I can't swallowed it
that can't be good for anybody anyway my
joke was I was trying to get people to
chew it as a joke right and I guess
can't swallowed it that's what happens
I'm like 3 a.m.
oh my god I'm gonna have to go back and
watch that that's really gross and I'm
actually got a you know keep it in his
body for like five years
it wasn't yeah at least it was like a
giant like Conan had like nine pieces of
gum like the hope of the entire pack and
he doesn't even own wrap and he just
foil it all it just goes straight in
he's a monster it's crazy just choose it
and then wow that's really gross and I'm
actually a little disgusted by um what
was I even talking about tickets to the
show all right great anyway I come to
your show and by the way it's like a
party like the warm-up is amazing
there's dancing candy there's t-shirt
tons of stuff to see when you're out and
before you come in and the the holding
area there's a music you play graphics
bobble head there's oh yeah there's like
the world's biggest buy there's it's
great a lot of fun
uh and you get to see this pretty face
right there but I'm pointing it out
packet oh sorry but I you might also -
yeah no they'll come to you ah - very
funny women
one of them's are right around our show
the other one has an amazing jacket and
is also hilarious and is also a writer
but not on our show please welcome Jesse
Gaskell and Christine Campbell
[Applause]
oh yes
I don't smell good cuz I've been up for
so long
and now you guys I'm sorry that's true
I'm sorry Conan's gum isn't here to
welcome you but it can't swallowed it
so here you guys go we got alpaca
evolution so introduce yourself to the
you got the old twitch chat we got these
Facebookers and we got YouTube like we
just saw that there was wine over there
this is all I want to do is play video
games and drink wine it this is what we
would be doing anyway normal this is
yeah this is kinda I mean this is how
how much money have we raised guys yeah
right for under privileged like at owner
weekend yeah this reminds me of I have
you ever done I did like a Dance
Marathon in college where we were
dancing for 24 hours to raise money for
AIDS research how much you raise I mean
I wasn't like stripping or anything so
you weren't specifically getting dollar
bills okay that's what I did okay for
myself okay to put yourself through cold
yeah exactly that's why I got my masters
oh that's why all strippers you're very
um we should introduce ourselves right
yeah go ahead
oh I'm Jesse I am a writer on Conan and
I've been working here for four years
she works really hard I'm Christine and
I am NOT a writer on this show but I am
a writer yeah and we met we were writers
together on a comedy show called the
dish which was a spin-off of the soup on
e it was for it was like the soup for
girls cuz they didn't know if girls
could watch regular soup
turns out they couldn't yeah
No - which was hosted by our friend
Daniel official who was Topanga on Boy
Meets World and every time I say that a
guy will tell me that that was the first
girl he masturbated to okay this isn't
going great and you were my boss for a
while
what was your boss you like can you come
in my office I need to talk to you and
then I go in there and she'd be like do
you like these shoes I'm thinking about
buying them
I was not great at being a boxer freak
that's the best kind of boss you want it
was really hard for me because I wanted
to be friends with all my employees all
of them well or a couple okay we don't
need to get into that guy said people
came here for the dish gossip my
favorite right that's most of the people
watching this right now and what happens
behind the scenes I don't even know if
they're still YouTube clips up there we
should find out let's put can somebody
get on that okay yeah we won't know if
you did but oh wow no wait maybe we will
we can read your comments here what's
I'm asking nervous to look no let's not
okay why am I here I think we're meeting
in like the bigger scope like light
right here I don't know I mean I think
just to be a destructive force
constantly or to to raise money for this
telethon yeah we're hosted we're not
sure whether it's or anything waiting
for it but it's something good I sure
yeah wine and for this alpaca oh yeah
are the alpacas Oh should we play the
game yeah let's let's check out I think
we can keep talking like wow yeah the
game because we had a lot of a very high
impact game so I asked specifically I I
saw this game called alpaca evolution
and I didn't want I don't like violence
and I didn't want something that was
gonna be like too upsetting to play I
don't know anyway like you know I don't
want a question of Grandma treatment of
like sex workers or anything so I have a
limit I have no idea what there might be
some some but not a disaster you
there I can't tell the difference
between our packets and llamas I think
they're the same thing
it's know one of them has fur that goes
all the way down to their feet and the
other one it's this we're sorry yeah I
can see the little they have it just
goes to their knees does anyone know the
answer to this question please type the
answers it says where is coming yeah I
know I've just Conan know if something
doesn't have to be here because best
game ever oh look someone said Jesse old
dorm life in here high dorm like oh
we're drinking white wine
oh I'm drinking red wine actually you
are yeah I cannot drink red wine in the
morning I can only drink like straight
Jack or white as soon as I wake up you
um I just wanted to to the dorm life fan
that was a web series let me do it with
a bunch of friends right after we
graduated from UCLA it on Hulu it might
not be anymore
one for a while and then we might have
lost our deal we had a deal with Hulu
and then I mean no one actually made any
money but it was cool because people
would see it on there and there and then
it I think it went away but if anybody
wants to Google to my house and watch or
come to Jesse's house you can watch um
okay so wait Oh someone says llama spit
on you well that's that's why we're
playing our packet of Revelation um okay
so I'm gonna try to I don't know how I
play um all right
they are pack a population oh my god
she's killing a pack oh my god the point
even me die
I just slurp him up hold on are you are
you watching this right now and they
have I punched a grant and I slurp up
the dead I mean eating out bad guys I
don't know you ever had alpaca meat I
have not have you know I would I went to
Peru was and they eat guinea pig there
I've not had that I've had EMU Oh have
you really in Australia that's cool yeah
what's the most exotic food you guys
have ever used yeah
um no cannibals please please say my
name let's see can you please give my
friend a shout-out all my friends are
gay
mine too that's exciting um they both
spit stomach now he's smoking a
cigarette wait a sec what okay winning I
think he just came
why is he smoking a cigarette I don't
know but there's a giraffe head down
there so maybe you can have that see if
that's on that oh no dad for another
game where you're just a giraffe
giraffes are crazy
don't you think giraffes are aliens I
there's no way that evolution created
giraffes I don't know it's just
let's get bananas oh that's punching I
know there it's punching them and then
you slurp hi Germany Oh life that you
know about your body soon how do you
figure you know that oh yeah I'm wearing
a bodysuit right now I don't know how
how shout out to all my ladies out there
but they it's so many things were pretty
who's the worst for - Ian oh my gosh who
do you think is the worst I don't know -
Ian oh yeah Corinne think you've in the
basement in a cage Chris Chris may they
never let her out I know there has to be
one member of the family that's good
they don't it's like a kind of you know
the Kennedy they never talked about yeah
and then they're and they become so yeah
oh no not that game they're saying not
that game not this game but you're
trending giraffes or aliens Wow
I mean this I this is just I don't even
know what else happens besides this do
you want to play for a while I don't
know I don't understand it I'll try
punching it it seems like it should be
able to do more than slurp I know I
punch and I slurp and and that's all I
do and then I go sit in the corner hmm
in fetal position
that sounds accurate maybe we should
have played a mile away
should be playing what are the violent
ones yeah I agree I don't even know much
about as much about bran - in looks like
he ate three of his own yeah box right I
don't even know how to make this okay hi
from Malaysia hi Malaysia I won that I
love Malaysian food I want to go to
Malaysia um oh so fun thing I get to go
on the travel shows with Conan uh it's
been and she brings me presents back to
you I always be a prison she brought me
a coffee last night
that's a noobs on it from Italy my
husband was like this these look a lot
like boobs
from Jessie and I was like yeah you
don't need to know in your garden has a
lot of questions about our relationship
that will not be answered not today
so look what someone asks where you got
your jacket you know where I got this oh
my god goodwill guys oh that's really
cool yeah shout-out to Goodwill sponsor
us yeah we should be asking for
sponsorships to Goodwill box wine haha
we're pleased perfect those two things I
mean really that's all we want
uh my getaway still um spray I gave in a
pack of really big muscle yoke don't you
he's getting too young he's really
getting married it out you how do you
feel about muscles on a man not not into
it
Leto I want like a light amount of tone
yeah you know what yeah like Oscar Isaac
someone who oh he's like probably
lightly toned and he's a little smarter
are you watching right now
I like that build a little you know what
though he's gonna get scat in some
really big action film and I know I got
Chris and I'm gonna be super annoyed
yeah but we'll always remember but tiny
and dark and I hope my husband does not
watch this cuz he's six five and he's
blind he's gonna be why did you marry me
I need to tell you your husband so watch
this he was like good luck at your
meeting today hahaha that's like
idea my mom might be watching I'm so
proud of
I always feel like she's the only one
who watches me on things and then she
just hits refresh and that's how I get
views on my youtube I want your mom to
kind of be my mom too because when I
told my mom I'm doing something she just
changes the subject she just lights up
and she's like I don't know what to say
about this about something else
I'm gonna take some more let's see if
there's any questions why are you guys
talking about your mom's yeah hashtag
stop talking
I'm not Darwin but this is not how
evolution works yeah I totally talking
about us that was a good burn um yeah no
I I mean it kind of is a little bit
because it's the strongest yeah I'm
right I need a like super Arnold
Schwarzenegger Oh fat guy I know who's
beating up the baby I'll pakka's it's
not pakka though if I win if I saw this
I'll pack on tinder I would be like
which way would you swag gonna see I get
confused I was like I don't know how
tender last I met my husband on Yahoo
Personals
that's how I want to hear more
what was the format for that it was free
did it disconnect
yeah that's pretty clear um it just
connected to your yahoo email I think so
it was like you can go on a dating
website that's not match yeah cuz that
cost money but I was like hmm I don't
have a lot of that so well but he was on
there and yes he's pretty cute and he's
an architect yeah that's like what
everybody wants guy no I married an
architect yeah you should get all get
married right away
Oh someone asked how many times have you
heard I wish that I had Jessie's Girl I
love talking about the song Jessie's
please let's talk about it because so
people always sing it to me but I'm like
no Jessie is not the name of the girl in
the song Jessie's is the guy a friend
yeah and he's thinking about his friend
thinking about a man he's in love with
his friend that's my theory about that
always kind of got to give it a vibe
yeah I know a little Rick Springfield
it's not the kind of water
he's depression appetite um I left I
used to think he was very handsome
yeah 1980 child but I wasn't born yet I
so I feel like if I were still in
college and trying to [ __ ] my way
through some sort of term paper I was
right about the homoerotic gaze in
Jesse's girls which class are you in
college I'm sorry I took a history of
rock class it was like you see only has
a lot of those fun classes that yeah oh
yeah music oh we could just yeah
acapella singing the 80s oh sure race
seemed to be a reason to change no
matter podcast oh yeah we're hosting a
podcast it's called how to survive it's
kind of like this except you don't see
this yeah well they'll probably put a
lot of pictures on the internet right
yeah
not of us but just of other deadly
crashes oh yes the podcast is about
survival skills because we were both
terrified what and yeah we're both very
fear fearful we live our life in the
fear base a lot of things yeah
especially now I mean I'm dying out
there guys are you scared
it's crazy uh but so we ain't hi from
China
oh hi China that's a bad place um can
you have a trap adventure too
are you allowed to type ends now again
in China was didn't um the president
band ends on the internet the letter and
letter N I don't know about that was
last was there a reason for it
I don't know I just assumed cause
anything negative might you it like if
you say something negative it would have
an end of it every word that is negative
has an N in it
I don't think so
this is not gonna cut a conversation to
have on the Internet
guys let's go dark we're like setting
traps for trolls oh yeah so this is tofu
hunter oh my God look like this
delicious tofu so who's your celebrity
crush
oh that's it so you already said Oscar
Isaac that's one of them but I could
talk about this for days okay we're
gonna you know I already crushes um what
about Oh what about the guy with the
puppy that I just sent you a picture
right hi Guatemala the little - rips -
you can loot you can lose some where is
Conan oh you like Conan yeah we don't
know where jeez but probably just in the
bathroom um yeah he'll be here what are
you guys doing Conan again jesse is a
writer are you down in I am a writer not
at Conan but we are doing a podcast
together called how to survive survive
not just me Norris we're acknowledging
the Norris thanks the know if they said
we were I'm the king of the north we are
from the north you Patrick
um oh wait yes by Monday the use of the
letter Ren was once again permitted
thanks for that info someone just
mentioned Jeff Goldblum and I have - oh
yeah last year I met Jeff Goldblum I
didn't know it sure liked him much her
like you did he touch me kind of for a
long time but in a good way I wanted it
um but so I got to direct him in a
sketch that I wrote where he played a
superhero therapist this was for comic
master and it was incredible Jeff he's
he's like the most Jeff Goldblum that
difficult could ever be nice work oh I'm
just hunting tofu I went I'm good
we need a tutorial there's a lot of
gunshots well you probably see a lot of
your actual crushes only what I meant to
comment that's true they do a lot of
them
one of my crushes Martin Short was on
that Martin Short that is a surprise I
have to say okay wait purchase I don't I
don't want to purchase a machine gun
please we really don't want to get nice
at this conversation oh god now I'm just
shooting at the good use some technical
step back I know um can I see it yeah
you take it um tap back again which
characters would you like to cosplay oh
that's fun I would be Arya Stark cuz she
I want to be I want a revenge kill on my
enemies I have a lot of them too just
kidding not really okay well then do it
Oh favorite superhero well we have to
how do you overcome writer's blocks
that's a great question just write badly
and yeah and then just don't worry about
it
mm-hm you just let it let it all come
out and then be confident that
eventually you'll go back and make it
good yeah there's a quote that Matt's
writing is rewriting and so really most
of the writing you most the good writing
you do comes on the second at least a
second draft if you're lucky
yeah or eighth draft or do I just kind
of go over it yeah and then you type it
and then that thank you
oh my god but then they start running
away tofu she's not another brother you
know I should be big
I do i I feel I thought I would not feel
bad about this but they're kind of cute
right
Oh mind um all of my crushes are gingers
and none of them notice me oh my gosh
you gingers are the easiest ones to get
because they get made fun of as a ring
up um many tips for aspiring late-night
writers trying to break into the
business right all the time right your
everyday you know some on Twitter yeah I
have a Twitter staff sketches and post
it on YouTube why I'm already done
I don't know
more hot no tech fail more cat more
huntin more huh mmm you know my brothers
are hunters but they don't shoot tofu
they shoot a deer so I should be good at
this just by like genetics how genetics
work yeah I don't understand science um
23andme probably oh yeah but you know
I'm free 23andme can I tell you yeah did
you see that episode of black mirror
where the genetics the the guy that was
Star Trek obsessed would take the DNA
and make them and make them to jellies
yeah I'm afraid that they're gonna do
that 23andme and I just beat Clemens
you're not getting me yeah I don't want
him to get it he's already got um what's
her name Oh Kirsten does yeah he should
he should and she was in that episode
but like really quickly she was yeah she
walks across the oh she walks it for the
office I did not see that yeah I don't
know why she was that she was just like
you have a good eye can you shoot the
worms too I don't know let's find out I
can't even shoot the tofo he's like
coming he wants you to shoot him look
look at me he's coming ask you you
better hey are you my mommy no your
worst nightmare ha blood it's kind of
good I get they not yet and then they
says where is Joe Durer waiting for you
um Joe Dern I don't know who that is I
think he's here for the threesome Oh
at what time is it where you guys are
cuz it's like it in one time is why the
bodice
here you can play okay thanks oh yeah if
you're in the West Coast
you're like watching us at work maybe
yeah if you're a coach you're working
about as hard as we are right now it's a
three-hour difference I don't know where
Shoney's your bags are banging Jesse I
think she's got her bangs
I think they look super cute um do I
sound like I'm from California
yes I work here we have a dialect we do
it's ours
oh I should be using different hands I
mean you know that it's a - it's a
two-hander has anyone ever played this
game before dad what are you guys like
okay
finland shoutout you guys have really
good public schools
hey germany my kids are german do you
have any advice for potential Cohn and
intern um Jesse I think that's a
question oh um you have to they answered
about a threesome but not about Conan is
required I like reading if you want to
be a Conan intern a lot of people
there's a lot of competition and interns
always want to try to get jobs here
afterwards but there aren't a lot of
opening so you have to really try to
make a an impression and you can do that
just by asking people if they need help
with anything
um you know just being extra should we
give them our ven Mo's that would
probably help oh yeah if you've been
knowing about our us our bank accuses
Jesse gasp oh I'm Christine can we go
find a son venmo yeah you could follow
us on Twitter uh that's probably where
podcast is I think that's the best way
for you to get help in this town is to
just really probably help us help us
help you but seriously you might be are
about it one day so I hope you remember
that I don't even know what's gonna
happen to television I feel like just
gonna be this so you might be getting
fired after this thing I'm just
oh except he's getting ready to walk
into any minute that's right yes he's a
he's about to get here guys um have you
ever watched an old Simpsons episodes
Conan row yeah
Conan Conan is I will say of all the oh
no I did bad um you want to do more hun
yeah I do
of all the places I've written of which
there are quite a few tonin is the best
writer host that I've worked for so
whenever he gives feedback it's like you
might be mad because you don't want to
hear his notes but then he's always
right I'm tapping for more tofu huntin
oh so you know what's up you're like um
Jesse doesn't need any pitches today no
not yet okay we could use a tough one
hey that's my boss I'm at um I'm gonna
be late today because I'm drinking wine
and killing tofu all her pitches are
about wine and tofu still trolling me
Matt I see you
target one tofu and shoot him until he's
dead and don't change otherwise you run
out of - thanks for the tip I'm already
out of ham Thank You Ana lumira how many
jokes do you write a day
well oh so our show is divided between
monologue writers and writers and I'm on
the sketch side but I do sometimes
contribute yeah I want a free extension
oh wait no no no you have to watch it I
don't want to add we don't want to do
that I like her mask though um I do yes
someone says anyone knows Jesse's
Twitter yes it is Jesse's twice I'm just
the past tense of tweets yeah in another
thing I don't want to watch that full
video do I have it someone asked Jesse
did you teach young writers is it
something you can teach her is it an
innate talent it's absolutely something
you can I think you learn get better oh
for sure I think that no one is just
good at it immediately you you have to
learn how to write because it requires
so much discipline but don't you think
how much of the job is yeah just volume
of writing and honing your writing so
you get better and that you can learn
for show specific boys because every
show has a different comedy boys and
their specific like rules I think
probably about certain yeah yeah I mean
there's definitely you know as when we
wrote on the dish we wrote a lot more
stuff about like The Bachelor yeah and I
don't think we write as much about the
bachelor on Conan
unfortunately cuz even you could watch
The Bachelor and get paid for it which
is good mass I don't
I only know something big happened like
he something Joe was a girl and then he
dumped her after they got back to LA and
then they all and then now she's the
Bachelorette that's I just knew there
was a lot about it on Twitter yeah I
only want to watch those shows when
somebody's paying me to do it and then I
have to yeah I only do things when I so
if you're if you're an executive
listening right now to watch The
Bachelor there's this is where
executives go to find new talent they're
all they're all my executives for a fee
someone asked is Conan overbearing ever
I've seen some videos of him messing
with co-workers and I'd be nervous
day-to-day I mean he does wander the
halls you hear his footsteps before you
see him kind of like where there's the
footsteps is jaws music playing we just
got some more ammo but no I mean he'll
stop in your office and then you're like
close windows of online shopping and
then you talk to him a little bit and
he's he's very nice but you do cut you
know you want to be funny for Conan
because he's fun course so you gotta
think of something to make him laugh
which is hard but when Conan laughs it's
so rewarding it's like the sweetest
sound in the world
that makes me sound like isn't everybody
a little bit in love yeah right that's
why we're all here
I mean bleh wouldn't a stayed here for
20 years
a little bit in love with Conan do you
want to talk about our guests coming
onto our pocket oh yeah yeah this is
exciting we got Barack Obama he's gonna
be we have two connections on our
podcast right so it's like the first
section is kind of like talking about
how to survive life with us situation so
it's gonna be an expert yeah we got
Beyonce for that yeah because we figured
like if anybody knows everything yeah
it's Beyonce
what doesn't Beyonce how does suck yeah
right that's true that's the only thing
she does not know she's good we were
gonna be talking about that um we've had
some some experience with sucking uh
someone asked what's a sketch that I'm
most proud of um that's a good question
I mean the the video I shot was Jeff
Goldblum was pretty sublime that was
really exciting to work with him um I've
gotten to write for triumph for the
insult comic dog which is really fun
that was also kind of a like wow I can't
believe this is happening mobility epic
um let's see laughs how do you survive
dealing with other women I mean yeah
we're fans some of my best friends are
women yeah my mom's a woman
my daughter's a woman Jessie's a woman
my one
I just killed a soy milk is that good
favorite 80s movie ooh that's a great
question that's a good one I see there's
so many I love that movie some kind of
wonderful like 16 I loved anything John
here yeah anything John Hughes Breakfast
Club anything with there's so many John
Cusack is the shining from the 80s is
that yeah I think so we're gonna love
terms of endearment upgrade your weapon
I don't want to pay really want you to
get a machine gun I know obliterate 10
tofu buck okay all right I don't know
that we're actually improving as we play
that I don't think so I think it'd be
just like laterally moving through the
game I am getting more buzz yes the
problem is I have to go to work after
this like actual work I want this thing
maybe you just need to keep drinking
I think that'll yeah I think you drink
more to sober up I just read favorite
pitch for the 10:15 meeting Matt my boss
Matt O'Brien is trolling me right now I
can't talk to women we give them advice
gosh I would love I think you were
pretty good at this
hey ask them questions like themselves
its eye contact you know very few men
especially on dates
surprising few surprisingly few
surprisingly few men ask questions
that's true about me and my Jessie's
milanese oh yeah I'm out there and
putting myself out she is she sometimes
she's fighting the brave fight I've
retired what else would you say if I
were talking to women yeah I think I
contact is good asking them
their interests in questions and
listening listen yeah you know that's
the thing with Matt early following up
about as much talking to women is
listening to women giving them a chance
to talk that's true
yeah yeah like you're listening to us
right now and aren't we staying
important things are you learning
anything is this someone asked Chris
would you want your children be writers
or hosts like a thing that came to you
and said they want to become one how
would you feel a writer air hose how do
you feel if they want to go into
Hollywood
mmm sad but if they want to be writers
I'd be excited
yeah riders are cool they're already
like writing little mini books about my
son rates a lot of books about farts and
poop it's five he's not 27 so you have
to be concerned although like actually
he cannot leave I'm right about Carson
he'd get a show on Comedy Central like
immediately and so they're already
writing books which I I feel that
excited about but if they were like I if
my daughter was like mom I want to be an
actress I would probably be pretty
depressed yeah it's just a hard life
because it's a lot of rejection it's a
lot of people telling you people telling
you look certain oh wait yeah you can be
like super tiny and really attractive
and people are always like that is not
what you are is not okay yeah you also
have to have a really small face you
know you Rainie yeah well in actors
always have you it's like their face on
their head is also small yeah whenever
you see celebrities in person are always
like you're so mini yeah you're like a
miniature version of the person I
thought you were yeah and I don't think
my kids are gonna be many people they're
not gonna be like Tom Cruise yeah which
game are you guys playing we're playing
tofu hunter yeah
a woman who wants to date the man's dad
who is currently dating the woman's mom
oh my we are on real I feel like this is
like a Dear Abby this just attained
Jerry Springer let's make this a Dear
Abby
and you guys I would today like
difficult question you have no just date
a different person yeah that sounds
really marry in America nowadays when I
get married later right yeah people get
married later for the tax break that's
the only reason I got married was for
the tax break
too bad participate with Conan Flula
came with us to Berlin and that was so
fun he's hilarious Conan have a massive
head he is a pretty big head that's
that's a question people want to know
but his he's proportional though cuz
he's overly when he stands next to me he
has a very short torso and very long
legs so his legs come up to basically my
shoulder and then and his torturing
right the size of my pinky finger yeah
literally that's not oh oh god that was
and that was the moment she lost her
absolutely so remember that remember
who's in on this so 5 foot 10 inches no
fight do you have tattoos I have a
tattooed you tattoo she's got her that's
people mines like hard to get to I'll
show you my attention I got my tattoo
when I was fighting my arm because I was
really and it is a where is Cohn and I
like that that's always in all caps like
many conversations I know blur like hey
how it is
[Music]
I'm a size four by the way yeah you're
creating unrealistic expectations for
well do you want me to be how does that
feel good yeah I want more is Chinese
food popular in America yes I just ate
Chinese food at last once a week I eat
Chinese food it's so it's probably
Americanized though right oh yeah I have
any time I don't know like actual have
you been too busy
I have not been in China you're probably
gonna end up going I hope so I hope we
get to go for the show that would be fun
what is your tattoo did you did you say
oh yeah it's um sorry it's Oh should I
just show it
it's a Venus symbol with like a laurel
wreath it's super feminist right it's
feminist but it's um it's also you know
about peace peace peaceful she's gonna
really yeah like yeah I have my tattoos
so woke mine is a black panther oh yeah
I guess so it's like that's kind of woke
I don't think so that was before the
movie - oh look skinny legends is now
trending see it was good week we like
called out that person earlier oh yeah
that's good thank you it's not because
they're dead you know when things trying
to hear like did that person die how
young are you guys oh my God we're so
freaking young we're like millennial I
mean - I think I technically am a
millennial but I still get carded young
but like at the grocery store like again
we're live this is this drinking at 10
a.m. and play interested
Hunter's yeah that's how you do it man
are you guys feminist yeah yeah we
definitely are what WTF you're not Conan
yeah I know it are you sure tell me
something I don't know about the amazing
costume and makeup department here yeah
Conan actually looks it's kind of like
this before he do you know he's maybe
not been to makeup yet and this is what
he looks like before you guys to make up
he could be right by in this couch I
didn't even know he could just be laying
back here the whole time for that just
so that you would just for the sake of a
big song life only existed in your 20
years I mean listen I don't like I don't
like my thighs if I if I don't have to
I'm not gonna do it I actually hope that
VPL comes back yeah it would make life
so much easier it would yes that's gonna
be my next activism campaign visible
panty line I'm just like I want
intersectional visible panty line a
whole sweat outfit not just wet pants
the whole thing is made out of fleece
I'm nothing
right yeah yeah I think that's everybody
my or that then just we'd have equality
right that's all it takes right I don't
I think I have to do we have to watch a
video I don't know
I feel like we've really not done a good
job marketing this I feel like okay with
the man someone that says Jesse where's
Brian McKenna well he lives in New York
now are you friends with Sona yeah
sona's amazing sone is hilarious
hello Brazilian living in Germany lol
snidey right
how much more comfortable would women be
if we were just all on Snooki's yeah all
the time you know what the Handmaid's
Tale costume is I mean that's true I
don't want the other fans that come when
I married man you disowned of work well
that's a good question I wouldn't say
she's the super committed to her job do
we want to answer this question does
penis size matters Oh
or do we want to take on Oscars and I
would say no to the other question I
mean you know it's it's not the size
how do you use it my god I can't believe
I guess I can believe it
I don't know Jessie are we in the
finally gonna does matter a little her
old is asking that are you 12
I don't want to be engaging in some sort
of hi from India crime almost we were
gonna go to India for our last travel
show and then our we had some some
employment issues but we're still gonna
go cuz India I'm already thinking about
what you're gonna bring back for me
hahaha you already making your list
yeah know what oh they want to know how
much you get paid you want to just shot
that up in coffee cups of wine it's paid
in wine and that's enough for me I need
more coffee I do too I really this was I
think this was a mistake maybe starting
to drink this early because it how could
they drinking early in the morning the
whole go wrong I know but then it's like
otherwise then you get a hangover and
then you have a nap at 2:00 p.m. that's
true you don't get paid naptime here no
I know we don't it's like this sounds
like a religion be a family leave and
paid nap time her adults I'm gonna let's
see why is tofu bleeding because we're
shooting her in oh my god remember that
time we had that boss and for some
reason we decided to send him like two
pages of the most disgusting period
enough I think we were trying to educate
him yeah he said something I don't yeah
we were trying to is this a good subject
to bring inflammatory we did I feel like
Japanese horn have you been a writer for
cons for years and it's
really really fast feels like I just
started here mo damage go yeah someone
says hangover solution keeps drinking so
you're always drunk working on it till
rehab
[Music]
I've given rehab I feel like when
celebrities got to rehab they're just
going on vacation Yeah right
that's just like a word they use to say
like someone says John says please tell
us disgusting period jokes I mean I
can't I think that sounds like a fetish
John yeah John we're not going to go to
the fetish inquiry jokes dotnet dot
slash work and you'll get all you need
is I'm sure there's something I'm what
country in South America would you like
to go to oh man I I love South America
I've been better
I as a young girl youth I really I was
born in Panama and I lived in Latin
America in Central America but then I
also studied abroad in Chile I know I
don't really I really cannot I feel like
we're supposed to pay more money to do
something else pocket Morty's they want
me to play pocket Morty's I mean I I
mean like Rick and Morty do let's see
what do you think comedy do you want to
talk about stand-up yeah I've done
stand-up I was just you know what last
night I couldn't sleep and so when I
can't sleep
I just do stand-up you just material in
my head really good I you don't perform
because but I'm like oh open mic and
everybody's gonna get like 20 and like
my parents don't give me enough money to
live in LA and then I'm up there like I
live in the suburbs it's that's I mean
it's like embarrassing there's a rumor
that maybe um there's those like um cuz
it's hard to stay up past the chardonnay
in my sippy cup kinda I know but then I
don't want to be like moms night out
yeah I briefly did stand-up before as it
was sort of more to work on material for
writing for late-night and I wanted to
get better at delivering my material
because I was in rooms where I would
have to say my jokes out loud and
suddenly it was like oh no I'm but I'm
an introvert how do I do this
do you wanna play hitman sniper it's 80%
off I literally think we just get to
shoot people we it's something it's a
game that's on sale or we could play
zombie adventures I think what do you
think out there Chronicles is like
you're just like living out loud or I
don't know oh they're sorry I don't
think it interrupts your stats okay yeah
we go to webinars on there okay I feel
like we've veered into bad territory
here that sounds like us what about Mars
you wanna play Mars see I don't think
these are on oh okay I think you're in
the store right now sorry hmm
yeah based on your recent activity okay
I'm gonna see it's hotdogs a type of
sandwich that's an excellent question
Leone mm-hmm
I feel like I'm on not call it a
sandwich what would you call it
I was calling I think it falls under
those foods that come in their own
container like um like a soup and a
bread bowl or oh yes we only have five
minutes left so get all your a burning
hot dog question and I'll say let's get
really a mugger to miss us if your hot
dog is burning that's a problem I suck
is a taco that's an interesting theory
oh yeah is it more of a taco than a
sandwich I feel like it's a hot dog it's
not it doesn't categorize into any other
group yeah maybe a hot dog isn't its own
species um how do you come up with new
ideas for episodes or sketches yeah I
mean wait I have to come up with a lot
of ideas every day we have a daily show
my Nathan Thursday usually the news is a
good source uh we we do a lot based on
topical material sir you like the wet
what now you're just looking at no no
I'm just no I'm just gonna play a show
what do you like right now um I'm
watching the crown it was good I just
got through it I enjoy it um what are
you guys I'm actually gonna miss you all
I know I'm not Natasha's not emotionally
prepared to miss us is that because
you're not gonna miss this earth no I
know that I was everyone was gonna be
really mean they're so cute if you don't
say sorry every other minute do you get
ostracized
I do say sorry a lot I actually
apologized the group I'm a little debate
we aren't going readings from Greece see
there are not going with the show just
no we're just going on our own you're
going and let's see is it possible to
get hired as a late-night read if you
don't live in a major city like LA or
New York yeah it's unlikely you have to
move there yeah you're gonna to move
there but um you know it's possible yeah
first time here I do think it's probably
easier if you're sort of already in the
in the area um cuz then you get to me I
mean so much of it is networking and you
meet people and you know the way I got
hired at Conan was I wrote on a spin-off
show that was hosted by Deon Cole Conan
writer and now he's on blackish and and
he turned back a million other things
but he he hosted a show called black box
on TBS I think it only was on for like
ten episodes but then that was how I got
introduced to people at Conan if I was
already here I think the best thing to
do - as soon as you get here - start
doing like some kind of comedy classes
like it you see your improv Olympic or
second city level epic just closed not
in Paralympic I know there the building
is spent for words at UCB or grounders
yeah and I meet other people who are
also doing comedy and then you start you
create your tribe making a network and
then they start giving you
recommendations of where you can go to
get the jobs and then you start as some
like lowly production to system where
you think otter way for a while million
years and then yeah you wanna do usually
someone will like get a job from Twitter
just because they you know yeah I gotta
be a using Twitter I can happen
like executives were throwing jabs at
them but and make your own people yeah
most people make your own stuff if you
have a successful web series that guy
won an Oscar he made a movie with his
iPhone tangerine oh wow that's right
that I'm an Oscar I think or a movie he
just made won an Oscar anyway just make
a movie with your iPhone and win an
Oscar it's not hard yeah why are you
acting like it's heartbreaking to show
business is so easy okay so it is time
to check in with common you survived
another hour without seeing Conan's face
you made it through um I'm so proud of
me so we're gonna throw to Conan right
now I wonder what he's up to okay ten
o'clock and I'm still brushing I usually
take medicine for OCD at 9:00 I've
forgot to take it today I'm still doing
this oh that was exciting
how funny um up next we have this is
really exciting so this actually
actually is exciting not just the
[ __ ] I was saying I didn't see the
Kenobi oh I didn't hear uh comedian Rhea
butcher is here so excited ah let's
check out this stand-up performance you
guys my name is Rhea butcher it's not a
fake name it's funny because it's true I
am butcher than all of you and by like a
lot I can tell when I got here a valet
came running across the street said oh
my god hey God thank god you're here we
have a bunch of manual transmission cars
and none of us can park them please help
us I said how many you got ten I'll take
two at a time let's get this thing done
did it right up I like to think about my
ancestors back in a cave back in West
Virginia trying to figure out what last
name they're gonna go with and one of
them says one day we'll have the most
lesbian great-granddaughter so from this
day forward we shall be known as butcher
and then the prophecy was fulfilled
I am on Conan with this haircut I also
love having this last name because I am
a lifetime vegetarian the last name
butcher had that irony my entire life
but not too much iron in my diet very
weak honestly don't even know how I'm
standing here my muscles are just made
out of sunflower seeds in Hope when I
were a Fitbit it just counts wishes
tells me to go back to bed my mom was a
vegetarian when she was pregnant with me
that's how long I've been a vegetarian
in utero I was born this way both ways
[Applause]
she got an ultrasound and it was just a
cube of tofu she was like is it a girl
or a boy and the doctor is like we're
not sure and honestly I'm still not
doctor was like but we do know it's
Silk'n that is a tofu joke for you I
know I don't know if you guys can tell
by this rock-a-doodle haircut and this
off-duty lesbian tractor mechanic outfit
I have on a tractor mechanic that
escaped from a 1940's prison but it did
take me a while to come out to my family
and I think for a couple of reasons I'm
from Akron Ohio from Ohio originally I
like to call Ohio the thinking man's
Indiana
a lot of my family from Ohio myself
included we're hillbillies you might be
like how hillbilly could you possibly be
well you know that phrase shooting fish
in a barrel
I've done that it requires a lot of
skill but I think the biggest reason it
took me a while to come out to my family
and specifically my parents is they've
been divorced my entire life I was born
in August of 1982 and they're divorced
in September 1982 I like to think I had
a little hand in that it's a little tiny
baby hand I'm also an only child which
was super fun when I was grown up I
didn't have to share my Hemans or my
shira's or my my pal - or my my pet
monster or my my buddy
but as an only child there's a genre of
toys that's pretty rough and that is
board games so I like to share with you
guys my top three worst board games for
being an only child
number three Hungry Hungry Hippos I win
number two is twister
I went again and the number one worst
board game for being an only child is
don't wake daddy because he doesn't live
here anymore
that was a twofer if I can leave you
guys with one thought it would be this
the band tool has made some interesting
music sure but I think they're a greater
gift to the world at large is the fact
that they got a ton of dudes to walk
around in a t-shirt that says to Lana
[Applause]
[Music]
did you what did you hunt some tofu I
mean we did we made a knight Wow I'll be
vegan lunch oh there we go
delicious and we finished our morning
wine and so now we're ready for the real
news with YouTube and the headlines for
us right now you're ready for the mid
morning wine yes perfect I love it
well thanks guys hello everyone Rhea
butcher everybody yes we got some look
heavenly 8-bit pixely clouds we brought
in the heavy hitters for the homestretch
This Is It this is it we have my gun up
so you have two more hours oh my god I'm
so happy I can't do it I was saving this
shirt I didn't realize when I bought
this shirt how absolutely perfect it
would be for this moment accurate
accurate exactly accurate so say hi to
Facebook twitchin and you - hi facebook
twitch and UTSA we're doing it on the
platform see you a shout out for Akron
hell yeah there we go the rear from its
Akron oh my god oh looks like a Conan
the Barbarian location I have a Michigan
I know that current live from Ann Arbor
oh yeah I'm gonna be kind of around
there this fall I love it I just fall oh
my god oh my god yeah this free days and
why cuz you're going on - I am going on
I love it and go to Rio butcher calm
please do how many cities you like
what's a width i scope of this - I
believe it's ten city oh that's so many
cities that's double digits in bakers
doesn't it say what fryers does fry
because you lose two in the roasted well
we're gonna play are you a gamer uh
somewhat I bought a PlayStation 4 just
to play the shows oh yeah we yeah you a
station you are 100% of gamer exactly if
you just owned it I think that's what it
is like you don't need if you own a
sword in my book you're a barbarian
perfect that's all you need you don't
need to use it you don't need to know
how to use it
honestly using the swords pretty easy
all angry barbarians writing and that's
there's more to it than just this
everybody gets so upset about that stuff
we're gonna play The Sims place in his
mobile I believe it just came out
alright anybody know anybody no I think
it came out literally yesterday so it's
hot off the presses
you got that impress that fresh new baby
smell actually don't smell this is
disgusting people have been using it for
24 hours horrifying yes it's it's great
you can see all the fingerprints this is
like a Mission Impossible subplot
happening over here all right so let's
customize our thing
what should our name be I like a name I
like like the American Gladiators like
billions Laser laser laser blazer blazer
that's great look there a blazer you
know cuz
like businessí and I think we want to be
upwardly mobile and I know right yeah
because the Sims is about making the
choices making better choices than
you've made in your own life I remember
playing The Sims when it was on Super
Nintendo
I love that you even question the fact
that you were a gamer Tiny Toons
oh my tiny let's hear some love for Tiny
Toons in the chat good lord I love it he
says I know what I'm gonna be wasting my
time with now I know Sims mobile it's
all right now wait is our first name
blazer as our last name blazer are we
blazer blazer I feel like blazer blazer
or maybe our first names BL and the last
name is Asia
I like that okay let's do that it's bull
first of all for short and then an Acer
can you knock oh there we go I don't
want to capitalize because I want it to
look yeah you wanted oh we're gonna get
so many jobs this is great all right
what is our head you know what let's do
a fun thing we just randomize it yeah
all right so cool today
let's close your eyes and and put it
stick out your finger and I'm just gonna
put this up you know here I'm gonna I'm
gonna be there okay just put your finger
down somewhere
perfect all right you know what don't
open your eyes we're not doing the whole
thing what is this Oh head with we don't
need to know our head with it gets a
little too much customize the player and
MOV the show is so excited yeah I was
like this is taking I'm gonna put your
trainer against some of these things I
don't even know what that is it's a
rocket ship what does that mean this is
doing your turbo tax's yeah that's
exactly it's okay alright let's pick a
color for our hair
I donno that's our skin but it still
looks cool don't wait don't worry and
let's get some cool facial hair it going
you know what this is is the fascia
layer I could never grow all right all
right that looks good it's really coming
through but okay fair enough
let's do our mouth oh this is important
oh we got good oh we got some good
supple lips I think that's important all
right now that's what's happening with
that good that's good you know is gonna
be fun I can't wait for you to see the
kind of person I created it this is very
exciting
oh let's change the hair we got to get
hair going on I was just saying by the
way I'm Karen I'm so jealous of rias
hair that's amazing big luscious hair
this this hair is just like white I
don't it's like a nice thing you know
what I think the grass is always here as
they say the grass is oh oh this is
great oh my god we looked oh all right
what do you think
perfect it's awesome I almost guessed
Zoe Saldana I was gonna say that with my
eyes closed now I would have been
correct I just have a very quick
question yeah have you ever dyed your
eyebrows no no is that like a paste
dip your face into like a no you
definitely just like pop it on there you
just pop it on right a lot of Vaseline
around it otherwise you're gonna have
fair enough I did used to bleach my hair
a lot which was really the whole thing
situation was like something do
something to my hair I remember I worked
for the show for a long time and back in
late night no doubt one of my favorite
bands
yeah and they were the and I it was it's
such a
the late night studio is very small yes
and so it was like you had to really ask
a favor if you wanted to go in and watch
a band I asked for no doubt by the way
this the only other band I asked for
Huey Lewis in the news oh yeah you gotta
do it you gotta do that you have to have
a I can't believe I lost this
I had a sleeveless Huey Lewis in the
news shirt where he's wearing a keyboard
tie oh it was made sleeveless like I
didn't make awfulest be still my heart
sleeveless be still my beating heart
rid of it like an idiot real my little
chicken heart is just fluttering away
water water
that's incredible it was a great shirt
and I'll never forget being anything and
seeing no doubt and like Gwen and what's
the bass player Tony
yeah Tony and I was like oh my god
because they had to perform in like oh
yeah this much but they were like
rocking it she was like move it I was
like that's what all right those are the
rock stars look like it was it it would
blew my mind yeah I believe it it was I
love you see no doubt yeah we got some
love for no doubt but the other thing
their love for no doubt it is hip to be
square it is hip to be square
I like let's just make this person as
big as possible I like you know because
I think like I feel like being tall how
tall are you
I'm five eight right that's 99 that's
good son perfect yes I think and no
offense to insure people out there
I like being talking I can reach stuff
absolutely I like to I'd like to get any
music yes then when you go to concerts
do you feel self I do you get very
self-aware as I feel like I do
as I go to a lot of shows that have
people that are shorter than me and I'm
always like very self-conscious of
standing right in front of people yes
because you're like I just want to see
this thing but I also don't want to ruin
your life
yeah I do feel that is that is bad
although when you're tall you can stand
in the bag he gets to see what I don't
understand about people that are very
tall and I get in the front like can you
not do not have a perfect view all the
time what
all right what's her body type we like I
wish you could do both the sort of
pregnant belly and the abs can happen at
the same time ripped pregnant stuck
ripped yeah we're looking good
plus I think we're gonna wear some dope
clothes I want as much clothing as
possible that's one thing that kind of
stinks I won't say being a big tall guy
as you guys have known over the past 24
hours I like to wear crazy clothes and
when I wear crazy clothes it just looks
like wallpaper looks like a giant human
wall yeah why it's a lion I can't really
pull it off although with the gray hair
I guess it's way all right what I don't
even know what's going on here there
should be a time limit for this
extremities all right we're looking good
rip to the great look at this but
profile what oh my god I'm just doing
biggest on everything because I want us
to be a powerful person okay go back
so style this is important hair and how
we did hair do we want this is what I
want to look like do jeans I like it I
mean they matches the color palette yeah
I'm not too into the RIP stuff though I
got a says we're not a fan I mean it's
coming back do this back in my day in
high school this looks kind of yes they
do like this you want ring this is AG
dorky friend all right I mean it's
definitely we are looking good glasses
yes these glasses though right let's do
it
I like it oh my god there's so many
things to do any options we don't see
yeah we can't even see our side
oh my god do you know what our glasses
match our buttons which I meant you
don't person to person blazer is ready
to go oh you know what they didn't have
a blazer sis is the best we can do yeah
man it's a little on the nose honestly
blazer we're in the fashionable all
right okay I don't know what to do I've
never played okay rolling bag now I'm
gonna see right off the bat I'm not a
hard shell guy I like like a duffel like
a soft up because I can shove stuff in
gym and just jam it in there yeah versus
like oh because I don't like constraints
absolutely I don't like luggage telling
me how much stuff can go in it no I tell
you how much the big one exactly toilet
is you happening clean up these boxes
this game is just we gotta clean up this
is what Oh
maybe they don't like this toilet the
toilet is just I mean to that it could
also be an avant-garde fountain I like
to leave it as is
they just moved in and yet there's like
a painting of them pretty presumptuous
get that set up right away yeah that's
what I do I always that's the first
thing when I move in I just put a big
picture myself actually you know what
this is a true story I already told it
20 hours ago on the stream but we did a
bit on Conan a late night where Conan
cut my hair and messed my hair all up
and dyed it weird you shaved it my
office huh and I'd to bust through a
picture of myself that was nine feet
tall huh and I have it in my apartment
yeah I'd print it out too so I have a 9
foot tall picture of my head it's
horrible well it's way that's why no one
ever comes over when they do they run
screaming in terror absolutely I have my
wife and I have a television show called
tape my wife yes now available on the
Internet yes download it it was gone for
a little while and now it's out there
seasons one and seasons to look go to
live butcher comment on there find it on
Google go go and we have
a running joke in our show because we
were given like this huge poster of our
faces and it's in our house oh my god we
need to combine our giant face posters I
feel like absolutely the one Emily
connects posters party maybe we could
take the note follow me on this maybe we
could take the two faces and make them a
giant rug a huge crazy rub that way we
get to keep the jerseys and walk on our
face which keeps us humble you know
showbiz that's important guys you got to
keep yourself humble all the time yeah
take my wife tell people off the show
you ever seen it yeah it's a show about
to stand-up comedians who happen to be
in a relationship with each other
and sort of a I Love Lucy if we were
both Lucy and Desi at the same time no
but it's a fun little show and on the
second season we got to hire a lot of
Powell's a lot of LGBTQ POS ladies folks
of color all kinds of people so check it
out it's just a fun little sitcom that
we made and it's about doing stand-up
comedy out in Los Angeles and when you
guys in its kind of it's correct move
around a little bit Curb Your Enthusiasm
me where it's like a little loose and
improv if evil is real it feels like
it's I'm guessing you're basing a little
bit like the pictures of you guys on
your real life Oh 100%
it's based on our real lives yeah
somewhat fictional somewhat real like
all just like sort of veritably
fictional do you like do you feel like
you started when you would have a crazy
experience started mining your life for
bits one hundred oh my gosh hilarious
[Laughter]
stuff like really happened but then we
changed you know names and faces sure
innocent or incriminate the guilty turn
in our own a good the guilty that's so
funny that's great I'm just giving blaze
or something I did it I gave him
furniture they need a there's a
storyline and take my wife about getting
from there we go season oh my god we're
recreating a new
seas that have take my wife right now
take my wife I feel like blazer they
need like more pictures on their wallet
yeah that's pretty
I mean if somebody's coming over very
true unfortunately extremely accurate
okay oh man sorry everyone
Sarah neighbors pretty dramatic where
are you going that's right
YouTube Zen you people are still not
exhausted you know what coffee is an
amazing thing Andrea's fresh I am fresh
I just had one cup of coffe that's right
I just got here in Orlando for less than
8 hours over the weekend so hello Teddy
was a great show there was also
borderline delirious hey eric ambler
dirk malar this is not a sim ripoff it's
actually by the people who made it yeah
it's not a ripoff it's a thing you can't
say like yeah this I'm not I can't even
think of a thing mr. Brogan okay so you
asked about the houses history or
discuss decorating well I'd like to know
if there's gonna be any ghosts if it's
hot all right so I'd like to know about
the houses history that's the first
thing I always do do you play HQ trivia
I don't but I am a huge fan of trivia
okay should be playing it problem
because I just learned to reach new
trivia that New York in the state of New
York you have to disclose whether or not
your house is haunted I don't know I'm
not sure I mean I guess you're getting
into opinions on the afterlife with
prospective house buyers which seems
pretty weird I just seem in San
Francisco and the Swedish Americans
Swedish American Music Hall and that
apparently is haunted
because they were like yeah the UH one
is a little girl that just walks the
hallways and then the other
somebody that hung themselves and they
were like CEA's latest not anymore wait
I'm a question though about the hanging
ghost yeah you would think that that
would only appear in one one area right
it's not gonna be like they're floating
around hanging but I don't know how I
don't get to be a pinata I know you go
like yeah how does it track how does
that work kind of like a bumper car
that's situation yeah you know a lot of
touring I know have you stayed in
haunted places you have any like haunted
experiences a ghost
absolutely stayed in haunted places and
I don't totally believe in it however I
believed in it this night and I was not
born typically on tour I was like in
town because my grandmother was in the
hospital and was all very last minute
I'm sorry I'm so depressing no but I
didn't have anywhere to stay
and the hospital if someone's in hospice
they have like a place that you can say
if you're out of town sure it was like I
need this so I wouldn't got the key the
chill-out lounge I call it as I had the
key and was like ready to go to sleep oh
yeah it's in the old like nurses ward
from when they were training here and
then I got there and it looked like I
had to sleep on stacked blankets and
there was like a razorblade collector in
the bathroom and I was just like this is
I'm I'm gonna die I'm gonna die you're
gonna your collection this is absolutely
you could yeah it doesn't matter how
clean a room is you can tell when it's
haunted oh yeah yeah blaze are outside
and the other person since they've
stolen our house from us oh you know
what haunted couch oh god oh no you know
you're honest Android user I love
apologies sir exactly yeah about an hour
and a half to go guys that's right oh
all right
that's right you know Li stacked
blankets though somebody said yes it did
not help my neck that's Jennifer Holman
I'm not sure you know a lot of people
have they said I think the thing that
everybody did with the Sims when they
first got the Sims would they would make
a swimming pool and then just let their
sims drowned oh that was the thing but
now I don't think you could do that I
think a ladder appears or they finally
gave them the ability to crawl out of a
pool which they should initially have
it's crazy oh my god am i working as a
barista I did this job oh no we're
supposed to be making better life
choices really way yeah I love that
Oregon Seattle I want to end up that
that's my favorite part of the country
Pacific or the West come along everyone
the gut yeah I heard they cleaned it off
though oh I don't know I've only been
there once so I can't I don't know about
it and my wife Cameron Esposito co-star
of take my wife took me there and I was
like oh cool and then I got close to it
was like oh my god this is forget that
it's gonna smell it it smells like go
speaking of God I'd be remiss if I
didn't mention this rehab but yeah when
the stream first started conan gave us
his gum and i was trying to get people
to chew it all right and i was like i
was a joke a joke yes chew Conan's gum I
go take any now Conan
yeah exactly I go to take a nap at like
three or four-hour - cue card guys Eric
it can't come in can't swallowed the gum
not only was in someone else's gum and
like nine pieces so you're talking like
a boulder situation he swallowed it
that's disgusting
so now it's inside of him for seven
years as we all know from our childhoods
and ate the ghost can ate together
Conan's my hero says erikak killer
amazing that's true that's amazing
holding it down that's right I just
earned a wooden metal Oh although you
know what there is this could be your
whole life but you can then go and do
some stand-up right there this is we're
getting like a microcosm yeah this is
for you that's free calories says call
me call me what call me does alright
that's pretty college that's true I
don't know what chewed gum what that
would be on my fitness pal
I'm not sure yeah watch out I'm not sure
what the carb situation is with that but
I'm just working an old job for my past
life that's right
Karthik kay we've noticed you there you
go he took it for the Coco team he
didn't need to take it Eric nobody
needed to touch the governing my god
you're killing it as a breeze you know
your previous histories of Rhys was
really coming it really is hell you're
really killing it right now what I need
to do yes
if you guys are just joining us with
we're with Rhea butcher go Tyria butcher
com2 ER date she's going on tour Oh
coming to a city near you
oh my god so many there's going to be
places in Pennsylvania and outside
Pennsylvania it's called the inside
outside Pennsylvania to our right yeah
all over Pennsylvania wait does your
tour have a name does it because it's
called the close to home tour was I
almost going home to Akron but not ah I
gotcha I'll be there I promise
gotcha Akron got at some point I'll be
in Cincinnati though it's like a
mathematical limit you always approach a
cur to never quite reach a you're just
I failed math so I don't actually know
if that's true or not why isn't it let
me letting me put the fridge somewhere
you never see a fridge in a bathroom and
I'd like to try it would be sorry
oh god really a lot of fridges and
bathrooms are you and re are you
obsessed with like junk TV oh yeah you
can't just watch one I like junk TV
because I love the show American Pickers
it's a show where these two guys named
Mike and Frank they they go and pick
through stuff and so they look for
things of value all across the country
so the cut are they like a little bit of
hoarder quarters and it's a little bit
of like what's the PBS show that I'm
blanking on the name Oh antique Roach
it's a little bit well but I really like
it cuz they're they seem like genuinely
nice guys they're really into the stuff
that they collect and then they also
it's not about like you know getting the
most money out of the thing like they'll
pay people more money sometimes like
that person's like Oh 100 bucks for that
they're like I think you're low on that
so like that's cool it's really cool and
I it's got that job I loved it you can't
do that love stuff I love little things
[Music]
I understand I love you so much my wife
oops my office what's in there she's
just like you guys have separate offices
oh yeah because of this stuff [ __ ]
[Laughter]
Calliope playing all the time constantly
that is hilarious
I am definitely you and I are kindred
spirits because I am a hoard I mean I'm
a hoarder straight-up I guess it's just
but it's all like like
it's all like tchotchkes and like huh
little like masks in like a flaw like a
ceramic frog and like a penguin made out
of topaz it's like these what am i doing
you're speaking my language but you know
you like go to something like a rock
show let's I'm not like a like a rock
out show but like a rock show and you're
like you see like a topaz penguin and it
looks so cool among all the other rocks
you're like wow this is great
it speaks to me it speaks to me this is
thing is talking to me once we take it
home so I buy it and I take it home and
then I put it on a shelf next to like a
bunch of other just garbage and it
doesn't look nearly as cool as you did
at the rock show oh yeah I mean I
understand but I when I see it I'm
imagining it right you know it's like
it's like you with your partner you grow
old together right you're both 80 years
old you look at your partner like oh my
god you're beautiful
because you're see I mean they are
beautiful they're a what it is you're
looking at the apes' frog over their
shoulder and you're like super exactly
but I'm trying to get rid of this so how
do you get rid of stuff and this is a
legitimate question I'm not even I don't
even care there was actually literally
asking what the Huey Lewis thing I got
rid of that and now years later 27 years
later however old I am I'm like ah it's
so mad that I got is it you need it me
too but I can't get rid of that stuff I
know there's an episode of that show
where guys like that motorcycle is a
time in my life and I was like that's
how I whoa
that's the teeth yeah I like a marker of
time yeah I don't necessarily think it's
materialistic because I'm not like
buying stuff and spending the money to
feel good about it it's like I like that
thing it reminds me of this time yeah
absolutely no I want to present agree
one of my friends and I are you give
tattoos I do I have an Ohio tattoo oh I
love which it gets weird
two of my grandmother's signature oh my
god that's awesome which I got off of a
chick she would find very funny that's
she wrote a check to cash nobody does
that anymore
and I kind of feel like tattoos are a
similar thing like tattoos are a thing
where it reminds you of a person or
experience or a time yeah and that's why
it blows me away when people get tattoos
that don't mean anything oh yeah
like you just walk in and get like
flasher would you like I guess you could
argue like it's reminding you of that
time you walked in and just got
something off the wall and so like one
of my friends who will remain nameless
but his initials are Casey Donahue kits
gets these tattoos like it's an eight
it's a Friday 13th so it's $13 and then
he has a crazy deer head on him and I'm
just like bro what's up but I think he's
going for some kind of like aesthetic
now he's just trying to fill it all in
yeah I know a lot of people that have
just sort of like the Rando sleeve which
I think looks I like the way it looks
what's on your lip how did you come up
with all of them you're like a wood elf
and then like know that you're busy yeah
exactly
I think you do reach I will say at a
Casey's credit I think you do reach a
critical mass of tattoos where it
becomes a sleeve and then it's dope you
know get in there though get the
transition is a lip can be a little yeah
sparse a little like what are we doing
here that's just like yeah right yes
exactly like a human fridge magnet
exactly I love it so this I don't know
staring at the fridge blazars it really
loves fridges and there's one thing I
know about laser it's that they love
fridge no lasers favorite thing
traveling is a great way to realize how
little you actually need every time I
come back from a trip I throw half my
stuff away that's true but I do that too
but only because I've bought twice as
much stuff that's right why throw them
away that's true
that's true some of you put on yourself
forever it should be something that will
never lose meaning I agree with that
oh by the way really I definitely have
been thinking about getting a Michigan
tattoo I love you you know because it's
something I'll never change about myself
because you can also get like a glove
and a scarf I do I will say Michigan
I'll people always forget about the U P
up top the Upper Peninsula so everyone's
like oh it's like it's like a mitten but
actually it's like a hand reaching for a
chicken finger all right which is kind
of more Michigan s yeah absolutely right
now question yes guys JoJo's in Michigan
nobody what is it Jojo Jojo is a style
of I guess you would say french fry but
like Oh cooked potatoes either gonna
take a snack cake no it's not as it's no
this is like a very Akron a thing whoa
but like there it's kind of like a
potato wedge but it's like long it's
like a dill spear Oh guys I've had those
I didn't know there are called Joe just
like in Akron we have a thing called
chicken and jojos like that's how people
order fried chicken vegetarian but I
want to name my children chicken and Joe
great buddy come on take my wife you
guys should star in it it's like oh I
like the idea of like a show within a
show you like me like I show my local
Larry Sanders is a show within a show in
season two oh my god really
what is it so Matt Braunger mm is love
me some plays a comic on our show he and
he's like he's a stand-up comic in real
life really and then stand up on the
show and in the first season I don't
want to ruin anything but he has a show
in season two and I am on it
and the scene is pretty bonkers and we
both almost lost our minds trying to
shoot it really cuz it's like a scene
within a scene and then a scene on top
of that scene it's very like Inception
oh it was the way was shot was like we
were both just going and I had a sinus
infection oh you're a crazy cough
medicine
is going like what's happening like
Katie crown is in the scene it is
absolutely hilarious it's so funny it
was wonderful I love that that's right
it was it was a lot of fun to shoot
socially we should be doing with the
show that's the perfect thing if you
have your own show you need to do these
kinds of crazy things I'm gonna tell of
course hilarious I like ours you know I
like our animated the way we're telling
this mm-hmm funny person do a set on
Conan I'm not so into this guy I feel
like I don't want to make it a
presumptions but this person is like
painted their hair and beard on looks a
little bit like a villain nobody's
talking about local news these days and
that's what I think I feel like he wears
too much cologne
I love swag gambler
I love swag with swag becomes a problem
oh my god times a problem I love free
stuff
I absolutely love free stuff it makes me
feel especially - but then I end up
throwing most of it away I got a gift
bag of like makeup and salty music I
went to one of my friends I used to work
for I think it was USA Network and they
had a Matt Damon
they're like honoring Matt Damon and so
he invited me to this thing which is
very cool like it was a whole Matt Damon
thing and we got we've got a goodie bag
of all Matt Damon stuff like Matt Damon
mag like three Matt Damon magazines and
like it's like yeah it's like Oprah
Magazine but it's just yeah but I just
found some cleaning out sighs I'm trying
to less of a hoarder yeah I just found
like it's like so like the 6 worst Matt
Damon movies are like in there nears
like what though
Wow even a word it's like crazy and
they're not like they're not like
blu-ray they're just like normal DVDs
yes they're single yeah they're kissing
swag bags make you realize how worthless
that stuff really is why I think it's
the thought that counts it is the
thought that counts and I mean people
are its advertising yes hey sbat good to
see you
I love it dancing like a chicken I like
it got some moves man just really sure I
call it a gift
you know when I'm changing I appreciate
said gift and not jiff yeah so then we
don't have to be mortal enemies cuz it's
not it's not Jeff it's beyond you
I know yeah it went away it's out in the
ether you can't change it now you don't
own gif and you don't own us you don't
know me don't tell us what to do person
Jodi says my mom wants to know where you
got the cushions behind you that's a
great question I'm going to talk a
little bit about Lance Zach who works
for chef and hooked us up with these
amazing cushions
Christopher Kumasi hooked us up with
this couch this is the couch I think we
use help me out guys in New York Bill
Clinton sat on this couch that's right
Bill Clinton we got some Bill Clinton
booty right here right here then this
area I think we're kind of both Oh sick
burn sick Bill Clinton booty burn this
couch every single person who's bound
the stream sat on the couch this couch
has been has seen a lot of things
including on the stream Conan O'Brien's
but was sitting right where you're
rising up his ghost the ghost of his
ghost in his hair is here thank you the
cast or not you're right with this with
the gift no hashtag turned it up always
I remember when DVDs first came out with
me
oh I remember that what does that mean a
minigame with a DVD uh weight minigame
on the DVD or DVD with a minigame duty
of the mini you oh yeah I think it was
like weird sort of little games based on
the movie that and it was like in the
menu is a menu yes whoa like did you
ever play there's also this game that I
loved and I have at my house and I've
played in a while because you need a lot
of people but it's called shout about
movies a DVD game awesome friends and I
used to call it shout at the TV it's so
much fun so like the one game is like
there's a scene from a movie and it
starts to fill in and you have to guess
what the movie oh that's awesome and
then there's like you know questions
it's a lot of fun I love fun and at this
point it's incredibly old that's gonna
come back though I feel like all that
stuff it's just a matter of time it's
like 10-15 years
oh yeah everyone's gonna be like like
DVDs Lois sleeveless shirts piano tie
not to bring up a sore subject of course
exactly exactly
both games in serial I don't remember
that at all tiny cassette things that
they sold @kv toys maybe players oh my I
did have a thing that like just recorded
like three seconds of your voice no not
a talk boy or girl it was a it was just
like a little cuz wait the talk the time
we think was like a tape and it did it
it did have a tape
yeah this didn't have a TV was just like
a we're like Oh
enjoyed the hell out of us did you ever
have a I think it's called a pixel
vision no I wanted one so bad I knew I
was gonna be right in your suite that is
definitely coming him alive I don't
think that's what I needed for the end
of the stream Rhea pixelvision talk who
are you Richard liquid nose pixelation
was a video camera that shot on cassette
like audio cassette tape yeah it was a
fisher-price yeah video camera that shot
one of those so bad you want to see what
it looks like you can watch the movie
slacker Richard Linklater whoa yeah did
he shoot it on picture out someone pixel
that's amazing whole section cuz that
movie which if you watch it now and
you've never seen it you'll be like
boring but it is like a fascinating work
of art I have a lot of stuff on hi-8
tape and I don't think that's ever
coming back I don't know many many thing
that's right oh it's some love for
Richard Linklater there Rita seniorita
yes we do have a twitch and your honor
right now because you're in the chest
most of today yeah you're owning this
conversations about film or should I say
ponying this game and pencil vision and
he got really mad he's like you need to
go have a life and water wolf we would
play this game all day it's amazing how
many sure changes have I had I don't
know I bought I brought 24 I brought 24
or shirts by the way what yeah oh my god
there's one that's amazing you would
like it's a orange plaid with blue camo
it's crazy
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
okay I love it always gonna clean up
coffee grounds Oh iris I get some more
coffee
this is guys hardest drink it for you
I'm just where I'm just oh yes perfect
and on the street I'm basically method
I'm method playing as you serve coffee
to people I am drinking that coffee
that's right you know Kurt Cobain post
John Green says Kurt Cobain posters
freshman year I feel like everybody in
college had like four posters oh yeah
they had like the Nirvana poster the
baby swimming right had some kind of
Bruce Lee poster if you were a dude I
think Scarface of course I would imagine
some ladies I would hope so and then but
it's always the same one with he's got
like the it's like flowing man entered
the Dragon where he's like this he's got
like the the dude remember there's a
dude with the cloth pants sure our knife
hand I think it three knives actually so
he's like been like this and he's like
the mirrors that's like there's like one
more what's the last one cause they face
and or are internally all right Oh Bob
Marley's that's exactly what it's may be
sublime sublime yep 40 ounces of freedom
perhaps ending our intern just worried
like with a worried grimace and so drink
it slow no more coffee on the planet
that's right there's no more coffee we
got to be in we done drunks at all we
done drunks at all oh yeah those are all
that but my my roommate in college
had an amazing poster I've never been
able to track down huh it was this girl
jumped kicking a dude in the face for
real and he's riding a bike okay let me
set it up I'm not singing from sure yeah
the dude is riding a bike okay and it's
like for like van it's like for like a
shoe company and he's riding a bike no I
know what it is hookups oh I think about
the backyard she was so good like
kicking the student the fence and like
his face was like they didn't fit that
is not a photo skateboarder told it's on
the face the guy Jeremy
something oh it's so cool
oh no it's definitely hookups I know
exactly what posterior tour you know
what I might get it that's a chest
tattoo I might get it you mean reminds
me of the time yeah you know I love it
it means a lot to me it is the coolest
poster in the world it's like she's just
like the dude I mean that's just it's
kind of before it was before like
jackass and all that stuff started it's
like you know like we did Big Brother
and and was like CK CK why that was the
thing I'm like kind of all well I mean
that's like Bam's thing but they were
all doing that at the same time yeah but
yeah jackass was definitely a
skateboarding thing oh my god there was
this a video whiskey three with this guy
boozy the clown and I think they would
all just take turns getting the
skipper's take theirs just doing like
crazy stuff and I remember my roommate
Tom when is boozy the clown for
Halloween and of course nobody got it
because they watching weird skateboard
videos you're an adult Suzy and they
were like what are you talking about
please leave our house okay Red Hot
Chili Peppers that was another one
that's a good red hot chili peppers this
is a big one oh no oh we got a what
create another sim
what happened I got a roommate oh we got
a roommate there we go just randomizing
I love it I don't want to change
Roxann daily at all wait can we okay
we're just
oh no we're cookie-cutter that's fine I
like I just wanna you know what this is
this is gonna be a good couple ya know
cuz I feel like Roxanne has some secrets
perfect look at that range yeah yeah
yeah three octave range there flirty you
play the instruments dirty I kind of
play guitar a little bit okay I mean I
love it I can play tab new quest
let's go to market squirt don't tell us
what to do how about that we're trying
to live our best Sims life
there's just money on the street what
money on the street good lord
life is that easy yeah let's do a
giveaway get away now what I give it
give it give me that's right blazer
don't need to put on the red light you
don't have to I love my favorite I
thought that she thought that song was
called Roseanne because new eyes open
eyes says Roseanne is coming back with
the original cast I love me some John
Goodman i I think he's is great and
everything he was you know so creepy did
you see what was the the Cloverfield one
in the bunker I didn't see that oh are
you a horror movie fan not really don't
see anihilation though and I loved it
have you seen it here's the thing I
don't want to get on a rant but you know
a rat's coming I hated the book okay
hey-oh viciously hated ivory and I had
to finish it cuz I hated it so much
yeah I had to do like I hate I was like
hate reading in the night hate finish it
just to be like just so I could say that
I hated it front to back of course
yeah I know so I so someone wasn't like
well the last chapter is really good now
be like oh really no I needed to have my
points but people are saying because the
third act is totally different than the
book yeah also I love Alex Garland great
I think a wonderful love Natalie Portman
Tessa Tom Oh Tessa Thompson
she's she's she's amazing everything she
does and and I hear it's really good and
I hear it
usually beautifully it really is and
like I I love going to see movies in the
theater and this is totally a theater
movie really I it's totally worth it I
think I think you can see it it has all
the pieces that you like okay see it's
true really like cuz Alex Garland didn't
he read the book one time and then
adapted it for them okay I like that
I mean the book felt like a dream to me
so I want to put that in the movie and I
feel like that's very that's cool I love
that thing that he does that I
love about it is there's no like
whiteboard moments you know that in like
sci-fi action movies where movies were
like they have to explain the prowls
right like an interstellar where they're
like they're like I know it's like a
flowchart of how the residents they
never do that like when they explain
things that's cool he uses one or two
sentences and you're just like there's a
lot of that it's it's very like there's
stuff I very rarely go to a movie and
then talk and think about it for days or
weeks in this movie I I felt that way of
them Wow alright you know what I love
like you I like a good spectacle yeah
even if and this is the difference
between a book alright there's a lot of
differences between books and movies
I've been up for 23 hours so they cut me
some slack but I will say one of the big
things is a movie can always win you
over with visuals yes let's say the plot
isn't so great let's say the acting's
not so great cinematography could be
amazing absolutely could be Gort you
know like so there's so many different
aspects which is also why it's harder to
make a great movie because there's so
many things go wrong but there's a lot
more redeeming qualities a book it's
words man it's just words and paper
unless you're reading on an e-reader
then it's words in ink or whatever
they're using these days but it's that's
all you got and with annihilation I
didn't I didn't like the the writing I
wasn't into and it was very obtuse and I
was like okay I get it yeah you're smart
you you know smart book writer I'm
taking a dump on a guy who wrote a book
by the way that's super popular he wrote
a bunch of books it's really hard to
write a book let alone three I mean it's
just I think it's a lot of time by
yourself and I hate myself so being
alone with myself for that long would be
just hell on earth but yeah so you know
I don't mean to rip on Jeff Vandermeer I
think it's great he wrote a book I'm
just not sure but I'll wrote some read
throw three three it's a it's a
gosh-darn trilogy yo it's a gosh-darn
trilogy but i do recommend going to see
it's gonna be on Netflix wide which is
weird that they put a movie into the
theaters and then put it on Netflix like
that's the old-school yeah and Gina
Rodriguez is really good at it it's
amazing there's some stuff in there that
just like you know when you see a movie
and you're like I've never seen that
before
whoa that's okay yeah that is extremely
fun I love that I've tried to go the
last time I mean like I really I like a
Roger Deakins I like gaya and I loved I
thought Blade Runner oh my god okay
that's crazy and so fun about another
theater oh my god a hundred percent and
it's funny cuz I saw in the theater then
I saw it on a plane don't watch it on a
plane no does it come through this
window no
Bladerunner on your phone not great I
watched it at home because my wife had
didn't see it and I had seen in the
theater I was like just so moved by the
movie and I love the original but let me
I'll tell you this this movie felt like
the way I felt about Blade Runner does
it mean yes 100% it it makes a movie
that is like what Blade Runner looks
like in your mind yes no I agree with
that that makes any sense at all because
I saw blade runner' when I was a kid
like on TV and syndication or whatever
and I remember just being like what is
this another stating it and then when
you think back about Blade Runner like
Blade Runner 2049 looks like what I
think about what I think of yes exactly
such an exact like how do you do that
how do you make a movie like that but
that scene where the emulator he's
trying to grab the emulator it loses all
of its impacting that in the beer to me
like a full emotional reaction and then
when you watch it at home you're just
like yeah he didn't get the vape pen
yeah right
I couldn't be far away boil it out for a
while exact we spoiled so many things in
this dream it's crazy it's also also if
you've ever wondered if I didn't like
the book annihilation we spoil them too
what do we got what do we do for fun sis
Jennifer Hallman what do you we play we
play video games I'm doing this we're
doing it made runners great
I like to go see sapa pudding explosion
Mad Max fury road was also really
awesome I'm saving the black and white
room I still haven't watched it cuz you
know it came with yeah yeah I'm just
like saving it oh my god so good that's
what that's one of my favorite movies of
last like decade I saw that movie four
times in the theater nice I saw it twice
and I never see movies toys yeah I saw
it the first time and didn't like it
what because really I was in one of
those theaters with the lay back seats
and that was the first time I ever done
anything like that and I wasn't engaged
yeah and I was like wow this is so
exciting this is great
yeah Naurang somebody eating pizza
dripping on themselves watch a movie
like I mean maybe a comedy you don't
watch a comedy like that but you can't
watch like an action movie like that oh
you know what the thing is what and I
hate it generalize here but I'm gonna
make a little bit of generalization on
the lay backseat theaters they also
serve stuff like soup
oh yeah like they're serving stuff that
has no business in it you don't like it
there's great mad at me about soup all
you want that's what I want to eat food
soup is a drink in a bowl thank you yes
look there's gravy and there's solid
food and that's it there's no soup so my
babies yeah what are we babies I mean
emotionally I am actually but that being
said yeah I don't need that in the
theater I'm gonna be fair popcorn is
also complete BS - because it's and the
loudest thing you really unhealthy for
you and you smell yeah you smell it's
unhealthy have you seen the butter that
they used to actually make the pop world
before they make it solid yeah it's a
solid Rick oh my god well on that
amazing beautiful visual I think we have
to say goodbye to RIA but go to me.com
alright to see live dates first tweet or
Google what's the name user again be
close to home close to home that's right
most of them not actually going on
that's right follow us on Twitter and
Instagram
Matt RIA butch
thank you so much stay right here we're
gonna check in with Conan O'Brien cuz
it's almost time Dan the stream Conan
what do you got to say okay it is now 11
a.m. if you've lasted this long
you've gone 23 hours you were one hour
away from doing what I don't think any
human in history has ever done which is
stay up for 24 hours watching something
stream on the Internet this is historic
now you're tired I'm guessing your
kidneys are shutting down
right around now you probably have full
renal failure your temperatures spiking
you're probably groggy making terrible
decisions you haven't been to work yet
probably just lost your job no one
understands why you're holed up looking
at this thing for 23 hours but you know
deep down it's all about getting to 24
you made a commitment not just to
yourself but to a higher power I'm just
looking at the ceiling height
I don't you just insert your own higher
power my point is this one hour to go
stick it out don't quit now cuz if you
make it to that 24th hour you will be
rewarded with so very little
hey everybody welcome to the last hour
of the 24-hour mobile marathon sponsored
by Google Play you guys can clap feel
free to clap over there go for the clap
our interns are napping
it's like it's almost like 11 o'clock
why are you still sleeping it's crazy
you wake up ah thank you for joining us
and thank you for sticking with us for
these past 23 hours cuz I'm assuming
everybody who's watching now has been
watching for 23 hours or else you're not
my friend
so we've been here for 23 hours what
have you been doing we've been playing a
lot of mobile games from the Google Play
Store we've had a lot of great special
guests we've had some awesome exclusive
music performances we've had costumes
we've had snacks we've had a lot of
coffee man I've had so much coffee I
think I can vibrate through a wall
before we introduce our next special
guest and our last special guest we're
gonna watch a little bit of his amazing
work it's Moses storm and here's some of
his stand-up take a look you so much you
guys are already one of the nicest
crowds I've gotten to perform for I'll
explain so I grew up on welfare my mom
is a single parent five kids no child
support and a lot of people find that
hard to believe
that I was ever that poor I think it's
because the way I look like I look like
everything just like worked out in fact
I look like the guy in the movie that
yells don't you know who my father is
and I legitimately don't I know who he
is but not like who he is you miss out
on certain things as a poor kid like we
never had ice cream growing up the
closest thing we had to ice cream and I
hesitate to even call it that is every
once in a while my mom would buy us that
like giant clear value bucket of ice
cream do you remember those but they
were like too cheap to even be a real
flavor we have white and we have darker
white this is true my mom only bought us
that ice cream because she needed the
bucket at Walmart a mopping bucket cost
$6.99 value bucket of ice cream $4.99 it
was cheaper than an empty bucket do you
know how shitty your ice cream has to be
great to actually depreciate the value
of an empty bucket that means people
were like I don't want that bucket if
ice creams been in there it might ruin
my dirty mop water
some food though way too expensive who
the hell does avvocato think it is you
know we grow those here right yet every
restaurant you go into avocados like
guys just so you know I'm always a
dollar extra oh sure sure sure you could
just buy me in the store but even then
you really can't eat me until I'm ready
Oh whoopsie Daisy doo dee doo did you
just fall asleep for 10 minutes because
in that time I've taken it upon myself
to go ahead and die yes now it tastes
like wet car keys meanwhile bananas only
grow in Central America they cost
negative 11 cents you make money buying
bananas
not only will repor I also grew up in a
big family so that meant I had to do a
lot of things I didn't want to do just
because it saved my mom like a little
bit of time like one summer my two older
sisters they went to this cheerleading
day camp now 5 minutes up the road was
the boys basketball camp that I really
wanted to go to but because my mom
didn't want to drive the extra five
minutes every day she decided oh you
should just attend the cheerleading camp
with your sisters basically the same
thing
those are two wildly different things
that's like if you were in a restaurant
and you tried to order a coke and the
server was like oh actually I we don't
have coke but is it okay if I just frame
you for arson basically the same so I go
to his cheer camp
miserable but eventually I make it to
the boys basketball camp because at the
end of the summer the big grand finale
for us gals is we get to go up to the
boys camp to cheer them on during one of
their games so we walk up there and
before the boys can even take the court
we have to show them what we learned
over the summer so we start them off
it's probably our most masculine cheer
which just starts with all right boys
show us what you got show us what you
got boys show us what you got
now I don't know if you've ever had to
cheer someone on as they bully you but
it's a lot like if someone shot you and
then it was your job to reload their gun
for them don't worry it gets worse
halftime rolls around now we have a
cheer with some participation built in
we have the cheer that goes we got
spirit how about you and then the boys
are supposed to go yeah and then we go
they can't hear you and then they go
yeah even louder so I step out I go we
got spirit how about you and then the
boys take this opportunity to yell cheer
queer and then I have to chime back in
but I can't hear you
in terms of audiences you guys are one
of the nicer ones I've gotten to perform
for thank you so much welcome back guys
it's the last hour of our 24-hour mobile
marathon sponsored by Google Play I
can't feel anything my hands these are
just neat sickles just being smashed
together thanks for sticking with us for
the last 23 hours thank you to Conan for
checking in every hour on the hour and
being here the entire time supporting
his staff guys we're super excited to
bring on one of our favorite people as a
friend of the show you know him you love
him he's got great hair
Moses Storm everybody wanting oh god oh
my god amazing gotcha gotcha guys let's
do it again I'm gonna juice you again
get out get out of the thing I'll choose
you again because I don't want to ruin
your thing all right ready all right
here we go
all right good see that coming all right
guys thank you so much welcome back to
our 24-hour full marathon blah blah blah
stream sponsored by Google Play thank
you so much now he's a bad guy worst guy
we hate him and we tried to keep him out
we locked the door he crawled it through
the window
please welcome Moses storm everybody
Moses what's crazy is you've been under
the couch for the last 23 hours that has
been insane that was wild that is bad in
this couch doesn't absorb nourish myself
it's amazing now we know where all the
weeping was coming from yeah we're in
the last hour this is our last hour baby
Blaine has been here most of the time no
only really two or three hours actually
it's been honestly just ride the
coattails of everyone else who's
surrogates last hour where do we do it
we're gonna be counting down probably
our favorite games yeah I'm just gonna
show you there's no real countdown
because at this point numbers mean
nothing to me
life is a
computer construct like Elon Musk said
we got 50 minutes right there I can't
even point the right way and I'm just to
show you some of our favorite games we
play in the Google place yeah
say hello to Twitter YouTube and
Facebook what app Twitter's that's right
well that's too bad that's a shirt or
see-through I think he just unbuttoned
his shirt this is not a see-through
oh no we get the green screen oh they
said definitely don't wear any greens oh
these are actually holes that are in my
chest heart heart murmur yeah they said
it was cheaper just to take it out that
makes sense take out the full hole I get
it I mean look you know you want to be
fiscally responsible if for sure hurts
to be alive yeah you're telling me
so how would we describe this room in a
word it looks like this is where they
record all of the hostage videos
it's just cords and like old now it's a
lot it smells like old rebel which is
weird because we haven't had any Red
Bull in here yeah I don't exactly know
what that is but you know it's probably
something I don't know I was asleep for
90 minutes I don't know what happened
although I do know that Kent I hate to
tell a story again but I'm gonna do it
Conan chewed a lot of gum and we left it
there and Kent swallowed it our cue card
guy swallowed it I'm like I'm like a
dare or just being dude we were that's a
great question I'm wearing after review
of the tape but all I know is you
brought a dog wore a robe and swallowed
some gum it doesn't make sense there's
no food in this room yes
[Laughter]
celebrities Benbow accounts and just
send them money that's the greatest way
you like any star yeah because you can
write them a message yeah that's the
thing it's a direct line to if if they
if a celebrity isn't on Twitter they're
not on you know any other social media
platform but they are mo just send them
just send them money like an unsolicited
money just one cent and be like loved
Ian and loved you in The Big Chill loved
you in the big show
once you get that cease-and-desist you
know your your clothes
is the question why would you why would
you like money exactly cuz you know it's
your pain you're paying for their time I
think it's working yeah
no no Court will touch it no court sent
you money and you want them to stop yeah
I think you're down to the core I think
most courts would probably touch that I
touch it yeah okay everybody all right
you're gonna play this game called my
name and Valley 2 which is a game we
started out with boxes in our one this
was our one minute one of our 1 we've
run out of ideas we're back to square
one well you know great ideas never die
but we have run out of ideas no we're
playing some of our favorite games cuz
you haven't been here you haven't seen
the games you've been playing
you've just been been mowing celebrities
and been mowing celebrities have been
under the couch yeah here in the couch
and let me tell you games are so
engaging just hearing them that's right
love I love video live streams because
nothing sums up being a little brother
like just watching people play so this
is a game where you are a woman with
your child getting showing your child
the valley there we go see told you the
vegetable in which row introduces her
child to the valley now let's talk about
the name row okay what is your opinion
on like hipster names like one Arlen
Specter I'm getting lit up in the
comment section for my stupid name and
let me tell you I understand it's a very
stupid at all Aaron blurt is a stupid
name Blair is like agree need to discuss
yes you're blurt is like well like a dry
heat where you're trying not to throw up
yeah you say blue and then way is is and
play something like a which is awful at
an airport also I don't know if Google's
reached out but if you could change your
name to Google Play it wouldn't be that
far for Google Play to learn exactly
where's my royalty check so bro so this
woman's showing her kid the valley yeah
sounds exciting that's what it is let's
get into it
wait so is moses storm been a blessing
or a curse for you in middle school it
was an absolute curse okay and then
I think in my professional life it's
been great because it's like oh people
remember it right but you always get no
matter what you do good does stage name
because very stupid right well it's that
stupid it's I would say it sounds very
Avengers II yeah
is that an adjective well I think it's
stupid for me just being like oh oh
white guy um if I had like maybe a cool
face scar and like new a magic is right
that happened right now that might be a
little bit better but to just be like
how long are the lines at Urban
Outfitters why don't you be Chad Michael
Michael but you know it is a kind of a
thing it's like calling a big guy tiny
in that way you know yeah you know like
it's kind of kind of works out I think
it kind of work to your favor a little
bit it does mean into it you know that's
a bit you just did right there that's a
tight five it's a Moses start tight five
by ten fun you can pick a stage name
what would it be
guys if you could change our names to a
stage name Oh something to do with just
our overall look this is in no way he's
gonna get mean at all let's not set the
chat up at all the riff on it I'm teeing
them up by the way they don't need a tee
up even they can do they've just
unloaded on us the whole time but they
know this has been a very positive one
chat if I can change my name yeah I
would well first of all I like to start
with a look I think the name comes from
the look okay you know what I'm saying
so you know Cape first of all half Cape
not a full key because I would don't
want to step on it you know cuz I also
like to wear really tall boots so yeah
this is all I understand that this is a
boot this is that goes all the way up
here this is boot up to here it's laced
all the way and the best weird yeah my
legs are just it's these it's just boot
and it's wet all the way don't sweat it
is it is the type of leather that you
waste oh that is fun cure does not
breathe
stormy Moses I like that one that one's
fun skinny ho ho door is a good one
Guinea hoarder that's you yeah hey you
see HP Hodor but then I lost a bunch of
weight by the way Conan's bit I used to
be pretend you're me and turn that way
just in the hallway when Game of Thrones
first came out yeah you should eat you
see like in the hallway just be like
taking me to the castle Wow is happy the
reason I lost all the weight so just so
he would stop jumping on my back stop
jumping I was annoying I think that has
more to do with your your fledgling DJ
career yes yes Hodor is a DJ right
probably pretty good one super boring
for everyone I've done nothing but just
walk around and not show my daughter in
this valley so you want to go to the
left and then twist the thing it's all
like MC escher esque I have no idea what
that means
okay pick the wrong person you know you
know the artist that does this the hand
drawing the hand that is not an artist
if a man can let me my fluid the hand
drawing that Waialua the hand drawing
the hand you know the hand drawing the
other hand oh my god and you've been huh
no God man oh good lord all the people
that are in the comments are like fake
there's no way to livestream this dude
pulling out this guy who's been out for
for sure 24 have you seen a poster they
did it's like a ball with the thing and
the the labyrinths going around with the
same you know emcee Esher like the thing
you know MC is not an MC it's not a rap
if my room is wall-to-wall Bob Marley
black like perfect that and bought that
Bruce Lee yeah just went through this
with reiha butcher uh sorry
look this is left okay you go over there
guys I didn't turn the thing you turn
the thing oh the staircase is a better
way what's the staircase that doesn't
end that's your thing I'm talking about
why he's good
this stone now you hit new this
staircase the dozen and such an obscure
a sure this is the one everyone knows
it's this guy sits right now who's right
on this does everyone know this guy's
yeah this is what case doesn't alright
it's good because the staircase was in
Inception - that's right a and that's
what they that's when they brought it up
okay fair enough
alright so it's more popular culture
alright you're doing great by the way
this is fantastic
you're right your job doing a really
good job
is like walking around the Glendale mall
that's right now let's talk about a
little thing called youth and
consequences your show premieres today
absolutely on the old internet YouTube
red actually it's you're ready that's a
good we already said there we go
you should present today premiering in a
show called youth in consequences on
YouTube Brad tell us a little bit about
it okay so if you're a fan of this show
or my comedy anything I do you're gonna
hate this show it is such an off-brand
move I last summer jose sees a whooshing
way to pitch a show I like it though I
like really go and let's follow you
what's what's the most off-brand move I
could make that would ensure all of my
comedy friends will roast me forever and
then I decided to take a job on a team
drama it is the only thing funny about
the show is that I was cast as the bad
boy of the show I'm getting arrested
kissing teens whoa that's crazy yeah Wow
oh my god now did you have to come up
with like a snarly fate like a do you
have like a boil in face even better
even better as a bad bad boy on a teen
drama yes from Dawson's Creek to to
Riverdale there is a there is a move
that I finally got to do I got to do it
in this show well it's my favorite move
it's an every teen drama the bad boy
does it and let me show you yeah please
let's cut to camera three let's cut to
camera three up here go back here oh
he's going back here way all right let's
get this bad boy move get the [ __ ]
get the full show we're in a full shot
okay wait hold on did ya get this camera
widget hook me up with that David there
we go this is the one okay so it's in
every teen drama I got to do it huh it's
a very simple move it's called getting
exhausted from just turning around
that's amazing it's so great
know what where did that come from did
you see that happen or did you eat kind
of the genre calls for I am sorry we're
doing it was like why would you do that
again the genre calls for it it's
basically in the script oh it hurts
they're scenes where I'm behind a
chain-link fence oh what a bad boy
my son it's on YouTube Brett as of today
they are streaming that's amazing just I
get the free trial the 30-day trial then
you could watch all the episodes can you
give us a little behind-the-scenes goo
what's something you know one says that
okay mine this scenes alright how was
the set how is the how is that was the
vibe on set with utilize right so I'm
most hostile vibes so hasta who's the
biggest prankster
so Jordan came by this very weird for
him to be at a teen drama thanks he
loves teens and not a weird way he loves
teen drama
it loves consequences and he loves
pranking team yeah I have to say if I
was George Clooney or on that level of
Fame I would 100% use my fame to be in
like YouTube red shows to be right to
like oh my god I make lateral moves make
beer step down well it could just cuz it
would be absolutely incredible it's so
much fun again so much fun a
game-changer like ass or like being like
the shape of water but as the amphibian
you know like any where his good looks
aren't going to know listen you you are
now invite your friend Lux to get in the
way where you don't you let's get weird
man come on Moony let's get weird let's
make some fun choices I love that you
think the starring role and shape of
water would be a step down for you yeah
a fish man would be like doing you guys
a favor here I guess what I'm saying is
like in sharknado 9 being the shark like
the voice of the shark yeah it's great
like being able to do that be able to do
whatever you want like Chris Rock it was
in the Berenstain Bears movie that's
great
absolutely you know I think that that's
a fun you know I know Clooney now is all
he's doing humanitarian stuff and that's
great
but think about us Clooney yeah think
about you know your adoring public who
want to see you do you think
consequences season two season two guys
playing a deck
playing 49 years old and your father
maybe he wears a leather jacket maybe
understand why you're such a torture
teen like that's what I got up in
awesome teen drama
when they showed the bad boys - yeah
because the bad boys dad is always like
a former bad so it's like it's like a
leather jacket favorite comments from
this from this chat view favorite cut
what's been my favorite comment yeah oh
that's a good question
I'm gonna say oh that's a great question
I like it we had a really good thing
going on a while ago where people were
telling us what jewel to hit and I
thought that was funny because they
taught so here's I'm gonna set the scene
for you concrete Oh Jason SH let me come
in here and we're playing some bejeweled
blitz no no how much I know about
bejeweled I don't know how much you know
about Blitzen but it was pretty awesome
okay know things about the words you
just said okay that's fine uh this is
the 23rd hour of our 24 hour stream I
just want to reiterate that for everyone
watching anyway and so uh
croteau says he's played this like forty
thousand times this game and he says
this is the one I always hit for the
prize there's six things this is the one
I always hit for there's nine things
this is the thing I always hit for the
prize I've never hit I've never won the
prize but I've never hit anything else
in case the prize happens I could never
live with myself so then of course chill
Emmys playing he asked the chat which
one should we hit they say not the one
that cuto always says they hit a
different jewel and it's the prize
croteau almost commits seppuku on he
almost kills himself on camera is
amazing it's such a great thing so I
like that that happened Cotto faced his
greatest fear yeah I've on camera of not
getting the right padule prize which
makes me laugh a severe hydraulics
that's more about here we're about
overcoming this is basically Sally Jessy
Raphael but that's a God's no one will
get this is basically no the median age
is about twelve dyers
median age but a lot of jordan / gfriend
fans oh my god so many that's much
commotion please I just can't I can't
watch you just do trying to be polite
but I was
this is this is just a relapse this is a
time cut to the game this game feels
like school this is just a time lapse of
you playing this game this is it I would
like the one that was I think it was
hidden folks that was great that was
maybe are you saying you want to playing
hidden folks now no I'm just I'm just
trying to go through my favorite games
but I would play hidden folks you want
to play hidden votes all right I didn't
or the one that you play with Mike
Lawrence that was Avengers one you're
really good you're digging deep I like
it deep because he's great you did hear
a lot of others are under the cap that's
amazing absolutely I love you under the
couch I love you no one we didn't get to
play was ridiculous fishing okay you
like fishing
absolutely it's ridiculous it's so fun I
was like what's a more engaging game
than just walking around fishing this is
showing you ridiculous this is alright
this waves are crazy this is cool that
you can do this up so I think yeah
you're trying to you're trying to get
the old fish how do I it's gonna hit a
summary easy it's gonna get watch it oh
there you go and then BOOM and I can
shoot him now you shoot him now you
shoot him well you gotta shoot him
tap on them yeah you should $3.00 per
fishing this is crazy guys I don't think
this is that's not market price for
those fish not at all
I think you want to get let's try going
deeper let's check all the snacks
we're already hungry we've been out in
the boat in ten seconds you got a praise
sandwich with you or something are here
we go buy my daughter fishing look at
guys thumbnail that was gross what's
going on impact
he's having a bruised thumb that that
nails gonna fall off look at that thumb
right left
well that's disgusting my god if you're
just joining us we are at the team cocoa
Google Play 24-hour mobile marathon
we're in the last hour is has been I
like you tried to read this sign that's
generated written crazy this is madness
everywhere the 24-hour mobile marathon
sponsored by Google Play this is Moses
storm right here huh
from the new show you think consequences
out on YouTube bread today yes my plugin
oh baby and you forgot follow this guy
on twitter and instagram at yo as a
storm
like it sounds exactly what I said no
I've had that name my bestest it's never
been a problem for me like sign for a
gmail account to be like Moses norm 88
no one else wants to name Aaron Blair
it's all very much the same way I love
it yeah what I'm seeing on this card
April 20th ice to Iceland I come he says
oh yeah are you hi nice to Iceland I've
been cheating on you know what network
projects I've heard a rumor of an
amazing story you have about shooting
this show in Iceland let's hear it did
you ride any dog that's here so I had
this idea for a show where this idiot
helps off the world and we actually
really do these things and the one we're
doing for Comedy Central is to fix
global warming
I brought about three tons of ice up to
Iceland that's a lot of us yes to fix
global warming so that will be out and
funny and April 12 in a pitch is just
like new that sounds like it's gonna be
super preachy Mo's East oh I like that
too that's kind of a fun day Mo's East
oh yeah we do have a middle name uh
Jacob oh yeah
so all together it's like that is Jewish
I was hoping it was also Moses so as
Moses Moses storm me to where Moses
storm I wish we had to say in our name I
wish I like seven you could be like okay
what are you doing so you can change
your name you can but everyone's like
what would you do yeah then it's like a
lot of judgment it's a lot of judge it's
a lot of judge we know those people that
like in their 20s change your name oh
yeah
I'm amantha now I'm probably just gonna
call you Sam my friend changed his name
I met him as Joe fusion Joe fusion okay
now I just assumed cuz you know why I
assume okay you are Joe fusion of the
yeah you know New England fusions or
whatever you know that that was just his
name but no he changed his name and I
was like well - Joe fusion it must have
been to change your name yeah must have
been you must what did you have before
cuz I have blurred that I haven't
changed my name Joe White Joe why Joe
it's a fine name
what do you do and change it to Joe
fusion what are you doing why so white -
Joe fusion what are we doing
but you know nice guy probably a great
fisherman I would imagine hunter game
devaron saying I should play a hunter
yeah comment up again let's find it the
hunter game I'm gonna look at my sheet I
can't remember what hunter game it was
yeah inconvenient truth to point out I
was just as boring it's just as long you
know what a game a really fun game one
of my favorite ones that we play yeah
was bad land bad land okay
do you like flappy bird yeah okay
first-person shooters like number one
really stop playing hey wow man
alright well let's play this game which
is not at all even person shooter and
then we'll play a first-person shooter
how does that sound no this room islands
we're gonna stream yes I think you know
what I think I have a first-person
shooter on here we do
I did resume ready are you ready we're
already on a Bharucha was great at this
no pressure but he was really good it
was really good awesome like a maze and
have like so good like I don't even know
how somebody I would be my you're
playing because it's this is
embarrassing you couldn't be better than
come on Kimmy that's right
now playing badly wow look how far
mobile games have come have you guys
played the game don't starve together
have you ever played don't start it's a
hard game is that what you've been
playing for the past 23 hours well
played
uh yes I have my whole life it's don't
snow really that's kind of life is it
half the lady woman back there and get
her some cough drops or something she's
dying it's somebody coughing we are
filming in an emergency room yes I I
just went to the emergency room because
I had that flu that was going around and
I didn't know that if you go to the
emergency room for the flu my girlfriend
made me go surprise I have a girlfriend
they they treat you like how to say they
didn't say they didn't say like you
don't need to be here but she did say
like your vitals are 88 over a hundred
just singing me wow so sassy with the
Royals and everyone's coughing in that
room if you weren't feeling great
you will devil terrible leaving your
yeah you're getting you're gonna get
something for sure but very fun guys
what's your favorite emergency room
stories go into grave detail i-i'll tell
you something I got terrible food
poisoning here's a tip I lived in New
York don't eat don't go to a restaurant
that's located in the subway station I
eat chicken tostadas
oh my from a side look that's a bad idea
I only eat at Penn Station quality
that's what we're talking it was like
grunt it was like in the Newkirk Avenue
same Flatbush yeah I know that's you
know what that face is that should only
be like a last resort like that's and it
was like a second bridge I was just
hungry coming home oh yeah here we go
cheat it on and eat it on my burrito man
oh wow you're bit real big anyway I eat
that guy really horribly ill watch it
and you know it and it's great you know
it gets you to the front of an emergency
room line fast passing out in the
emergency room that'll get you're right
about that yeah I was waiting for like
three hours and I was like time to use
some drama right yeah that stuff my old
drama shoe it was yeah I woke up on a
gurney with an IV and it was crazy and
it was fine but uh and everything was
great but also a gunshot wound yeah now
you go in you want a flu shot and we've
been waiting three rows show yourself
one thing I'm not proud of foot is while
I before I passed out
it while I was waiting list forever and
then just throwing up all the time the
emergency room waiting around there was
a kid and I'm not proud of this this is
one of my lowest points who is like
coloring and like being a real jerk and
he like kept kicking me and he was like
I was clearly like sick and he was like
yeah and he like went to the other side
of the room I stole his crayons and put
them in my pocket so I could cook you
monsters I was at my lowest point Moses
that was it I couldn't handle it I could
not handle it
I could be get this shot and cropped out
a little more I just realized what I was
doing and this was a bad meme
go at me I'm trying to find this thing
on here I'm probably gonna have to
install the guy with just fine
O'Malley's laughing tapping yuck it up
over there I don't let her touch Oh Lily
you're really going you're really good
lighter touch yeah just like a quick I'm
like your aunt with the father like text
weed oh yeah hold it hold it like in
that oh there we go so it's paying
attention all right resume oh okay
that's what I was doing right now Abed's
like dammit he knows the secret yeah
he's for sure watching what's the stream
coming out guys this is the highest
we've ever been yeah the highest any any
stream since I've been on Teen People
it's true come in let's just Conan
where's thrown in where's Jordan
actually saw Jordan on the way and
almost hit him with my car so I wish
that there was no almost in that
sentence okay great I almost hit him
with my car because he did not see me
because member hold hold down member
hold
oh yeah I got so caught up in this thing
if you just hold it it'll just do it
Jordan
you can just do its thing you just hold
it you don't need to stroke it you can
just hold you could just literally just
hold you just press guys is someone
gift.this yet you could just stroke it
you older than be doing this so anyway
so uh Jordan walking in yeah I almost
got hit because I don't even know this
but when he leaves the parking lot
Jordan puts on who can only be described
as a Mortal Kombat style fishing hat
over his entire face this is just this
right and he's got a telephoto lens the
longest lens you've ever seen he stops
in the middle of the crosswalk he snaps
Warner Brothers the place he works every
day and shoot
and then gets outside the stage and
snaps I snapped the photo of stage 15
and then and then before he enters the
building because he knows he'll get
roasted takes off the Hat folds it you
can fold a hat and then walks into the
building like that didn't this happen
he's got his rituals no one knows why
that was this morning if we went to his
office right now he would have the Hat
and I want to see these terrible photos
he'd be just collapsing his giant lens
into a thing and putting it in a drawer
god knows what he's got in that office
right that's crazy
it was it's like if you went to Sammy's
camera are you like can I get a perverts
lens
he was so much longer like he looked
like he bought parts off the dark web to
make it oh the fans stopped you see that
makes sense
yes exactly so anyway you can just
[Applause]
[Music]
slansky story oh you know what was it I
saw him come into work today in a giant
mortal kombat style fishing hat and I
almost hit him with my car cuz he did
not see me right and then and then and
then he pulls out a giant telephoto lens
snaps a photo of just the Warner
Brothers lot and then walks in like it
he is everyone asks me about Jordan yeah
he is that guy do sometimes is he has a
little bit of self-awareness and put a
little mustard on the ball but not much
shockingly little and when you see him
in life as you did he is a legitimate
oddball yeah he's a very strange man
I've never met anyone like Jordan and I
yes we saw I saw him in the wild yes he
was dressed for the wild first of all I
want to congratulate you on your new
venture yeah show a very funny guy very
and I regret telling you that I am in a
teen drama it's a report for me
absolutely there's this janitor that
died at the school
no she fun to make up no as far as this
like ghostly like figure that comes in
so insulting so insulting he kind of
he's weeping a lot no I mean I could do
the weeping he's got a good week I I
feel very in tune with the mind and the
spirit of a teenage girl and what she's
going through
oh that's great yeah so I'm available
okay
you with with with just a little bit of
work okay so be a a seventeen year old
girl okay so if you're in a team drama
has a seventeen year old girl you're
constantly getting broken up with yes
and I put the bad boy in the show so you
probably named Gracie yeah
Gracie I'll be Gracie for why I'm I mean
I'm I'm really into you but you're not
into me and yeah skew on the look give
them the okay yeah so as a bad boy you
start your scene with getting exhausted
from just turning around yeah so okay
that's you so you think everything's
normal but I'm acting a little weird and
but I got a register that you're acting
a little weird yeah so I'm excited to
see you once your name on the show uh
its hook on the show okay is it really
yeah okay so let's go hey look hey
Gracie
hey luck has a kind listen uh I've been
thinking about I don't know what's
thinking right [ __ ] there comes a time
in my life where I need to tell you
something I'm on my app that's not teens
talk they found something in my locker
today school you guys find something in
your locker
what happened it was marijuana
comes to a screeching halt and I huge
that's a big issue it's a huge deal
right so I get arrested you get arrested
what do I do
Gracie I just think I'm gonna be in and
out of juvie I I don't see how this is
gonna work hashtag it's important to
yell on a show
listen keeps the teams engaged you're
going I'm gonna wear a crop top okay
and will you see what I look like in a
crop top that's a real thing because I
keep this tight
how much is uh how much is crop how much
I want to think the shirt to end above
my net the shirt to be up here and then
all this I want new and then I want that
little chest hair line that goes down
yeah leading the way so to speak soar
down to southern climes implying that I
actually had to wear crop tops for the
show the Wardrobe people cut the shirt
and they didn't measure for the role of
a normal t-shirt people are logging off
as I tell this story and the shirt would
just roll up so you got a little belly
you got just a little belly yeah yeah I
like that I can do that look at that
animist prime does conan stand outside
TBS studios and plays guitar disparage
for spare change I would kill to do that
I doubt I would get any money here most
people in this lot despise me they see
me as the local creep who moved into the
neighborhood and lowered the property
values but I would love to do that I
would love to make my money on the
guitar do you think you could do that
you could go in disguise and go to like
a subway station you know I feel like I
could probably do that but I get
recognized no matter what I do if I wore
a full mustache and two eye patches and
a Darth Vader helmet people be like
Conan big because of my body and the
tone of my voice I know it is Jordan
real don't move
and that's exactly how you guys I've
been inside a closed elevator and people
on the outside of the elevator have been
like Conan Jordan real weird crop town
off the weeping what are you doing
you're not you're just playing the game
still ways you'd be a social person I'm
what do you guys have a moment hours ago
since the 360 live show at Comicon wait
a minute came back to the show
oh that's right each other since he came
back and did the show killed it thank
you so much that's six out of ten but uh
but no I bet so I thought I think you
guys yeah you inside the comic-con yeah
your shows we've got a hot roof you're
on the roof Oh such a hot roof yeah was
I so bad for you guys cuz that would go
up there to visit you and in San Diego
and it's that time of year and I would
walk out to see you and my feet would
stick in the hot tar and that was also
our green room up there yeah yeah just
start moaning in the Sun right but it
all worked out because Chris red is now
having one most successful four seasons
on SNL yeah who's to say who did better
who's to say you're standing next years
well actually you're sitting next to me
if you were standing next to me I would
say you were doing better
we'll run a couch with this guy sorry we
gotta give it up for Chris rip it up
this way we're having a good time you
know yeah we're going through our
favorite games from the Google so I just
wrote it was so hot last year said bear
ski what what kind of comment is that it
was so hot looks like there's an old man
watching cats are my favorite I don't
digest onions random comment is that
keeping the conversation spark going I
think it was hot last year you're right
and guess what the peanut is neither a P
nor a nut it's a legume not a good
observation tomatoes are actually a
fruit yeah I'm that person
yeah Oh what's happening nothing I
believe we'd been up this long well I
want
[Music]
yeah I know what I did I make big
appearance in straw tonight every now
and then I changed after my first
appearance on the show 24 hours ago
that's right and I changed just now and
but the rest of the night I just was
urinating into my pants
sir you know you actually awkward yeah
well I was off and then someone said to
me you're not on camera for an hour at a
time you can use the bathroom right and
I then realize it was a mistake that's
crucial well I thought it's solidarity
it was nice to me to keep wetting your
pants over and over and because we as we
had it's easy to do right there's
viscous and slow as yours it's not
really a problem yeah I must immediately
dry through comes out Oh very true
it's like a banana smoothie it just
comes out very slow sweet yellow not a
healthy man I could have gone my whole
life without hearing that Maxim one
thing I do want to say is I know Kent
yeah you know who works for us in cue
cards I know who Kent okay he was here
and you know you started off the stream
a chewing-gum and we had it here for
most of the stream Kent
swallowed the gum did he really he and
I'm not even kidding about that
literally swallowed the gum Wow his so
that's I don't know what you should do
with that information I just thought you
should know not really good person Rises
me yeah Kent Kent all he does is go to
Phish concert it's true yeah and spin
around if you want to get Kent's
attention all you have to do is say hey
wasn't fish great the other night not
and he'd be like they were awesome I was
there they were so good at the middle
very Sports Complex in Connecticut he
spends all of his money going to see
fish his eyes are always looking in
different directions in another world
and he's also a little secret he's 65
years old that radical surgery
oh I just got a message on my phone okay
see this shows it's all happening in
real time
that's right this is proving it's live
yeah I'm just curious who is it that
just
oh it's not coming up all right that's
right I do you want to play a little bad
land here nope okay fan not at all ah no
I mean I love bad land don't get me
wrong when I'm at home all I'm doing is
24/7 bad land
bad land is my jam that's right
someone's asking and if you know if
you're gonna star as the night king and
the last season of Game of Thrones I
think we can say right now no you're not
gonna be the nut King unless he's in the
game well the night King already there
is a per character that's true yeah oh I
see it's all like Conan so pad right
yeah okay we got me but you know you got
me dude if you could be a game of
Thrones who would you be like who do you
watch Game of Thrones you Game of
Thrones yeah yeah I'd be Sansa Stark
yeah you heard it here first guys Sansa
Stark who in doubt who would you to
watch off right because every comment
that my set on the show was like dunno
Joffrey did stand up Joffrey around the
eyes see just here to hear I do that and
just say okay this is it Colorado it
exists is intolerable yeah your jaw may
bring me some animals yeah your Joffrey
ask yeah I do see it now I do see it
that's true that's your people want to
know Conan where we're going next man
where the travel shows well we have a
travel show that we shot that is it is
it's coming out and I think it's gonna
it's a couple of weeks away and
basically I call [ __ ] I can say that
on the internet right sure sure I call
[ __ ] on Jordan shlonsky George
Lansky's been acting like an Italian man
for years and so I actually surprised
him I put him on a plane I'd take him to
Italy and I make him I try to expose him
as a fraud to all the people of Italy
and it's really fun I think it's gonna
be a very funny travel show
and it has no social purpose this one
[Laughter]
except calling him out as a guy named
shlonsky from Long Island it's not the
Gianni from all not so it was we had a
lot of adventures I'm sure some of you
followed along with that or saw some of
it out there but that show is gonna have
some very funny moments I promise you
the man's a freak and it was it was it
was great was really fun and how do the
Jordan thing first get started a lot of
people don't know the origin outside
from Jordan just being a weirdo haunted
it first
we noticed him around the office and
then back away night yes back at late
night and then there was some strike
shows where we had no writers or
anything so I think he took me out in
the hallway and showed me his Harrison
Ford whips and he showed me how to use
it and crack it and then he also showed
me how to tango
and he did it with no irony no sense of
like this is funny and it was hilarious
and then Frank smiley one of our
producers said because Jordan talks all
the time about Italian food you got to
take Jordan out to an Italian meal and
we'll shoot it just the two of you and
we did and it's one of my favorite
all-time you can look it up I'm sure
Conan's Italian meal with Jordan where I
go I think I get pretty blasted what you
need to be to have dinner with George it
was it was I went into treatment shortly
after that meal and for pasta not out
and that got it started and then I swear
to God everywhere I go in the world cars
stopped people in traffic and people get
out at an intersection and say what's
with Jordan so that's my gift to America
it's the it's the craze that's sweeping
the nation wait have you met Jordan in
person aside from him with her car one
time he floated into my space in San
Diego the bathroom and he was already
there and he goes you guys's voices
reverberate really nicely together
that's a really that's a thing he said
and I have been thinking about it every
day every day someone said glad you
brought the cutout to Korea it's hard
Conan's might that's nice glad you
brought the character Korea we brought a
cutout of shorten Oh Conan punch Aran
every time you mentioned Jordan alright
now listen there's controversy about
this because I know that there are
people in landed like don't be mean to
Jorah to uh to Aaron don't hurt him
don't hurt him I don't think I hurt you
know you work out sure all I do is hit
you as hard as I can and I'm six for
about 195 pounds yeah yeah you and you
lift weights yeah so I mentioned Jordan
how many times you think since I've been
out here I want to say a hundred and
eighty two that's not feel like this
alright how about just one good one
[Music]
actually no it actually it doesn't hurt
go in her sometimes it hurts it for sure
hurt I'll tell you one time it actually
really he kicked me one time so we went
bowling
we did a bowling thing with the nerdist
people and you did push me down and kick
me that actually hurts I was I apologize
because you're not good you're not just
a good at kicking you're just you know
you had what punching you have control
of your body I didn't have full control
and I was doing it for comedic effect
yes I wasn't really trying to kick him
but I did give me holding shoes on and
he kind of slipped and it was it was it
was a kick and they were metal tipped
bowling shoes which I had requested they
had a spike on the tip but yeah that's
know otherwise it's only emotionally
yeah oh there's no no physical damage do
you want to hit god you guys talk you
want to have Moses never been hit by God
I don't want to hit you he's a Joffrey
we know Sansa Joffrey on the show Sansa
his job because he was a real jerk yeah
here's well director so really I mean
you did this would kind of you know
would really use the money from the
lawsuit already got that sweet sweet a
YouTube red cast whereas like a piece
that's this baby would blow that's rude
YouTube brat if you've ever been
watching YouTube and thought wish I was
paying for this you know I say I feel
where the genius was who thought of that
I know we're giving this away for free
wait a minute I have an idea I hey wall
let's offer it for free over here does
it have a concierge section service
where we charge for the same thing no I
know you gotta learn nothing from C's oh
yeah I know you guys already kind of did
a little bit of a why do you keep
playing the game role-playing require I
can't stop and so I just thought it was
I can't tell how much of it is using
some argument or are you just being an
anti-social it is honestly a lineal Kree
it is a very fun fun I can see what
those Bert are those bird know they're
like little I don't know what they're
little blobs with things okay
hairball I'm not quite sure yeah they
don't fly well they don't know they're
terrible flyers
I call him a millennial oh no what I
call anyone a millennial who's under
fifty fifty you know yeah generation now
yeah all right what do you think about
Conan as like remember talking about
your bad dad and the show do you think
you can be like a bad I can be a bad dad
yeah I'm a bad dad yeah yeah you
disappoint me
oh yeah you could be so the bad boys dad
in a teen drama usually has just a very
out of place leather jacket so if you
think you could pull that off
oh my where is a regular guy I do I wear
an out-of-place leather jacket you do my
favorite Bagdad of all time in cinema
the Green Lantern that Ryan Reynolds is
in the dad
the actor was who's the I he's like a
general yeah
and he's the he's the he's like a
general and his son is the Green
Lanterns friend who later turns evil
because he's so jealous of the green
last night so anyway there's a scene
where the son has some special new power
we can hear his father's thoughts okay
and the father who's a general someone
online I'll know what this is the father
is like the son goes hi dad how are you
and he goes I'm good to see you son and
then the son can hear the father's
thoughts and the father goes what it is
[Laughter]
important that about this son the minute
they hi son good to see you with this
appointment check it out Goku's they
Ryan Reynolds Green Lantern here's a
funny scene it's it's in the first maybe
20 minutes of the movie probably
available on YouTube Road yeah yep yeah
yeah you could you could for sure be
that absolutely and dad
this is what not only had we seen you're
off Conan what do you think of pineapple
on pizza despise it and my brother Neil
loves it and my brother Neil what he
does this is a true story if I'm with
him he will he'll say should we get
pineapple pizza and I'll say no and say
okay so we don't do is he'll order a
pizza margarita which is what I like and
then a pineapple pizza which is what he
likes and then it comes and this is a
true story
my brother Neil who's a couple years
older than me will then start eating the
margherita pizza eats both and he
quickly eats half the margherita pizza
or two thirds leaving me with a slice or
two then he retreats to the relative
safety of the pineapple pizza because he
knows I cannot follow it's so ingenious
so smart
that's what Neil O'Brien does it's gets
like Game of Thrones Pete it is just
genius and I know exactly what he's
doing you eater you die Game of Thrones
Pizza guys we've only got five more
minutes is incredible twenty no one's
ever done anything for 24 hours in human
history it's true this is a whole new
level we are there's a lot actually
oh really is that a man oh I thought we
were like the first people yeah not even
close so he's got a 2009 you can
probably get on the ground floor or
something so he did this all for nothing
I was pretty sure that this was smashing
through a whole new reality I didn't
realize that has anyone okay it's tapped
into reality I would say smash we've
definitely broken through some kind of
crazy I drank so much coffee I've had
drank I've had I don't think I have
drunken I have done I have done drunken
I had that meet no it is it's me done
drunk and coffee much me done drinking
coffee much yeah yeah me done drunken
coffee
I mean I'm drunk I got my hair doing
look at that yeah I think I do I hate to
do this to you kind of I think people
would love to envision to touch your
hair again because what they weren't
here the very beginning of the stream I
think it'd be great
grab that virtually guys get all the way
up to the screen this turn this into a
time graphic give me a big wave I know
this is what they're gonna do you say
that what you're gonna do you're gonna
what I know you could put in here and
then my head no yes is why I thought of
and when I went home and did so I could
watch myself this is definitely the end
of a 24 hours dream for sure 100% we did
it you know there's a lot of people that
said there's no way you could pull this
off and then there's a lot yeah then
there's a lot of other people that said
what do you mean it's quite common today
you know I'm really glad you asked
because I don't know we've had a good
show man did you check out our Monday
show Oh incredible tell him that was so
good wait our Monday
this past Monday that's funny the show
that we did yes that decided we had it
was great to me yeah Kevin Hart was
you would not pass a sobriety test right
Kevin Congress on the show yeah I was on
the show and it was one of my favorite
that's right he's always funny but I
think was my favorite Kevin Hart
appearance but he's amazing he talked
all about his Super Bowl wrestling we
did for Kevin show that's right that's
gonna be coming out I think any day now
that's right yeah what's that next week
I think that's coming out that's not
that's for Kevin show and looking
forward to that I also loved yesterday's
show with Martin Short
one of her favorite people of orange
shirt one of the very rare people who
was super funny when he was twenty years
old and now at the age of 85 still just
aging really well yeah because someone
asks you a question does it mean you
have to answer to guys a minute 30 left
in this 24 hour stream this is crazy I
can't believe highlights view but if you
highlight this is the hard one I love it
we're with highlight we're with good
friend
I'm with the good friend and I'm with
Conan this is awesome it's this really
great - I'm having a great time
especially there's a huge 24 hours of
life that has been lost it's 24 hours of
not knowing why Leia's babbling on and
on yeah I mean I meant positive things
it didn't sound that positive it was
pretty it and it was all it was very
pretty classic that did resolve not to
get super mean no offense I oh you've
heard the song before you heard this
song before it just rhythmically works
really well that's right sick can you
see the second verse about Moses quickly
Moses is the best guy
Moses is fun even without coffee
Moses looks a lot like a black-haired
King Joffrey you know I'll tell you
something else I have to be very careful
when I play never to play a recognizable
tune because then we have to pay for it
and those things cost a lot of money
they do and I know a lot of songs and I
yeah I'm sorry I can play them pretty
well but when I'm on camera they tell me
Jeff Ross the producers like don't do it
don't do it don't do it don't do it
don't do it don't do it you can't afford
it so careful you want it down this
building you like this show ya know when
you look at what it's like backstage at
our show there's live stuff wandering
around yeah there's just piles of manure
there's sawdust
there's people naked fighting each other
yeah yeah you go to The Ellen Show oh my
god everyone's riding around on a on a
you know pot like a portable like what
are they called Liv a segue I'd Segway
and they're all I come to Ellen have
some gold have some gold have a
flat-screen
welcome to Ellen and then you come to
our show and it does look just people
weeping and it looks like yeah when you
first come into our marathon
bye thank you to Moses store and watch
you think consequence very ready Vera
120 times bassist or young fellow watch
this guy on his show it's called Conan
and it airs tonight with an amazing
amazing budget who got out of it don't
know you're writing checks right now
it's that your brain can't cash you got
a great I'll tell you who's on hey you
know whose eyes you start bleeding out
of my eyes Middle East that's right
there can be exactly we want to thank we
want to thank assess you know your skin
I'll be mo Welch I'm Dre do we shake our
Levin Chris Hayes Chris Brinson jump all
adjacent let me I'm in future
Levi mcdougal Mike Lawrence we're doing
it all we're good enough huh
Alisa samples
[Applause]
Jesse gasps new Christine Kimmel uh and
I read a butcher thank you guys thank
you to Google Play
[Applause]